Hey everybody. Ruby Central and Shopify with Mike D'Alessio and Evan Phoenix. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. So 99 episodes ago, we covered Ruby back in 2015. If any of you kind of heard that episode, you might have been sort of shaking your fist in the car or at the stereo. Patrick and I have done a little bit of Ruby know we did our best to do it justice but i'm so thankful that here we are almost 100 episodes later the podcast has really kind of come a long way i'm really uh it's kind of wild just thinking about it but we have two amazing folks who know ruby way better than patrick and i will probably ever know in our whole lives. So we have Mike D'Alessio, engineering director at Shopify, and we have Evan Phoenix,
大家好。Ruby Central 和 Shopify 携手 Mike D'Alessio 和 Evan Phoenix。节目交给你了，Jason。大家好。所以在 99 集之前，我们在 2015 年讨论过 Ruby。如果你们当中有人听过那一集，可能当时会在车里或者对着音响挥舞拳头。帕特里克和我对 Ruby 有所了解，我们尽力做到了公正客观，但我非常高兴，差不多 100 集之后的今天，播客真的取得了长足的进步。我真的很……回想起来感觉挺疯狂的，但我们邀请到了两位对 Ruby 的了解远超帕特里克和我一生可能达到的程度的杰出专家。所以我们有 Shopify 的工程总监 Mike D'Alessio，还有
long time Rubyist on the show to talk about Ruby. Also talk about Ruby Shield, Ruby Central, how Ruby plays a big role at Shopify and plenty of other companies and, and really just dive deep into where the language has gone. So thanks so much, both of you, for coming on the show. It's great to be here. Thanks for having us. Absolutely. Happy to be here. Cool. So maybe we'll jump in just with a couple of backgrounds. Maybe, Mike, you want to go first
节目中的资深 Ruby 开发者 Evan Phoenix 来聊聊 Ruby。还会聊到 Ruby Shield、Ruby Central，Ruby 在 Shopify 以及其他许多公司中扮演的重要角色，并深入探讨这门语言的发展历程。非常感谢两位的到来。很高兴来到这里。谢谢邀请我们。当然。很高兴能来。酷。那我们也许就从各自的背景开始切入吧。Mike，要不你先来，
and tell us sort of what your journey has been like, what your experience with Ruby has been over the years, and what kind of is the journey, the path that took you to Shopify? Sure. I guess my journey to Ruby starts before I used Ruby. When I started my career, I was working in physics and then later financial services using Fortran and C, which are two of the least user-friendly languages you can imagine. And so by the time I hit like mid-career, you know, mid-2000s at this point, let's call it 2005, 2006, I started to use Ruby for a couple of hobby projects. And it just, it made sense to me, like something clicked, like Ruby is just, it's very easy to use. And you can tell that one of the principles behind the language from the creator maths is to make developers
给我们讲讲你的经历是什么样的，这些年来你与 Ruby 的经历如何，以及是什么样的历程和道路让你最终加入了 Shopify？当然。我想我与 Ruby 的结缘始于我使用 Ruby 之前。当我开始职业生涯时，我从事物理学工作，后来又在金融服务业使用 Fortran 和 C，你可以想象这是两种最不用户友好的语言。所以到了我职业生涯的中期，也就是 2000 年代中期，姑且称之为 2005、2006 年的时候，我开始在几个业余爱好项目中使用 Ruby。这让我觉得……一切都说得通了，就像有什么东西点击契合了，Ruby 就是……它非常易用。而且你可以看出，该语言的创造者 Matts 背后的理念之一就是让开发者
happy. Like it definitely made me happy and something clicked in my brain and it became my primary language for writing like one-off scripts or even for doing bigger projects. I tried as hard as I could to use it for my next full-time job, which I did. And it's kind of been downhill ever since. I even got my start in open source with Ruby as well. I started contributing back upstream and some very friendly people in the Ruby community were very encouraging and it was painless. And I said, I guess I'll do this some more. And so now I've been using Ruby for something like 16 years and showing no signs of going back to Fortran at this point. Nice. So like, that's a really interesting thing. You fell in love with Ruby and then you said, you know, I would like to find a career where I can do Ruby.
感到快乐。它确实让我感到快乐，我脑子里仿佛有什么东西被激活了，它成了我编写一次性脚本甚至更大项目的主要语言。我尽最大努力在我的下一份全职工作中使用了它，我也确实做到了。而且从那以后，事情就顺风顺水了。我的开源生涯也是从 Ruby 开始的。我开始向上游贡献代码，Ruby 社区里非常友善的人们给予了极大的鼓励，过程毫无痛苦。我说，我想我得多做点这个。所以现在我使用 Ruby 大约有 16 年了，而且目前完全没有要回到 Fortran 的迹象。太棒了。所以，这是一件非常有趣的事情。你爱上了 Ruby，然后你说，你知道的，我想找一份能让我使用 Ruby 的职业。
And so my impression is that might be challenging in something like physics. And so you probably have to switch disciplines, right? So what was that like? And it must be a really interesting sort of set of calculus there to say, okay, I really love Ruby. I love physics. I can't really do both of these. I'm going to pick Ruby. And how did that whole thing go? Well, for me, I had already left financial services where you're expected to use C or C++ or, you know, on a bad day, Fortran. And I was already working at a small startup where I had the opportunity to play around with Python and PHP and Ruby. And like Ruby is kind of what I really like. I really rocked it and I really understood it well and it resonated with me.
所以我的印象是，在物理学这样的领域这可能具有挑战性。所以你可能不得不转换领域，对吧？那段经历是怎样的？在那里一定有一套非常有趣的权衡考量，你会说，好吧，我真的很喜欢 Ruby。我喜欢物理。我实际上无法兼得这两者。我要选择 Ruby。整个过程是怎样的？嗯，对我来说，我已经离开了金融服务业，在那里你被期望使用 C 或 C++，或者在倒霉的日子里使用 Fortran。我当时已经在一个小型初创公司工作，在那里我有机会摆弄 Python、PHP 和 Ruby。而 Ruby 正是我真正非常喜欢的东西。我真的玩得很转，而且理解得很透彻，它与我产生了共鸣。
So then my next job was at a small startup with a friend from college. And we had the opportunity to build a new app, essentially for, let's call it energy trading. It wasn't really trading, but it was a company that owns some power plants. You need to bid your energy into the market and do some light trading. And I was like, I'm going to write this in Rails and it's going to be great. And it all came together in about three weeks. I had built a replacement for their previous system that looked almost identical. And that was the opportunity for me was to kind of put a bunch of my skills together and write this new greenfield thing in Ruby at a new job at a startup where we
所以我的下一份工作是在一家小型初创公司，和一位大学朋友一起。我们有机会构建一个新的应用程序，基本上是用于——我们称之为能源交易。其实不是真正的交易，而是一家拥有一些发电厂的公司。你需要把你的能源竞标到市场上并做一些轻量的交易。当时我就想，我要用 Rails 来写这个，这会很棒。大约三周内这一切就都完成了。我为他们之前的系统构建了一个外观几乎完全相同的替代品。对我来说，那个机会就是把我的多项技能结合起来，在新工作、新初创公司里用 Ruby 编写这个全新的绿色项目，我们在其中
had a lot of flexibility around the tech stack. I think that was the key bit for me is Ruby was not a common language in 2007. And so I had to make my own opportunities in a way. We've come a long way since then. I think Ruby is very much enterprise-y at this point in time for a lot of companies. Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. We talked to a gentleman earlier who worked a lot with Dask and said something similar where they really wanted to use Dask and they found the only place at least local to them was a startup. And so it does seem like startups are a good place to have sort of more greenfield, which is kind of counterintuitive, right? You would think like big companies with zillions of dollars to burn would be the place to go to experiment with
对技术栈拥有很大的灵活性。我认为这对我是关键的一点，在 2007 年 Ruby 并不是一门常见的语言。所以我某种程度上必须创造自己的机会。自那以后我们取得了长足的进步。我认为对许多公司而言，现在的 Ruby 已经非常具有企业级应用的范儿了。是的，这非常合理。我们之前和一位与 Dask 合作很多的先生聊过，他也说过类似的话，他们真的很想用 Dask，并且发现唯一的地方——至少在他们本地——是一家初创公司。所以看起来初创公司确实是开展更多全新项目的好地方，这有点反直觉，对吧？你可能会认为拥有巨额资金的大公司才是去试验
new languages. But in practice, you find that they've built all the infrastructure around C. And so everyone's using C. And if you want to use Ruby, you're going to have to fight through like 17 layers of the organization or something. Yeah, I think that you're right on the money that it does work that way in large companies. And I think it's economies of scale. I think at some point, companies get to a size and scale where they say, listen, exceptions are really expensive to track and take care of and limit the flexibility, right? Like, oh, you want to do this project in Haskell?
新语言的地方。但实际上，你会发现它们围绕 C 构建了所有的基础设施。所以每个人都在使用 C。如果你想使用 Ruby，你将不得不突破组织中的大约 17 层官僚作风之类的。是的，我认为你说得很对，大公司确实是那样运作的。我认为这是规模经济。我想在某个时候，公司的规模达到了这样一种程度，以至于它们会说：听着，追踪和处理异常的成本非常高，并且会限制灵活性，对吧？比如：哦，你想用 Haskell 做这个项目？
Fantastic. You're one of three people who work for the company that know Haskell. And if you leave, then we're stuck with a Haskell project that nobody understands. We'll have to throw it away and start over. Like there's a lot of risks that big companies just don't want to take on new languages and new frameworks a lot of the time. Cool. That makes sense. So you're at this energy kind of management or energy trading startup. Did you go from there to Shopify or was there a string of opportunities in between? Oh yeah. There's a bunch of stuff in between. So from that startup, imagine it as I wrote some code for six months to try to get us
太棒了。你是公司里仅有的三个懂 Haskell 的人之一。如果你离职了，那我们就得接手一个没人懂的 Haskell 项目。我们不得不把它扔掉重来。大公司在很多时候就是不想承担采用新语言和新框架的巨大风险。酷。这说得通。所以你当时在那家能源管理或能源交易的初创公司。你是直接从那里去的 Shopify，还是中间经历了一系列的其他机会？哦，是的。中间有一大堆事情。从那家初创公司开始，想象一下，我写了六个月的代码，试图为我们创造
a beta version that we could build and sell. We were in startup mode. And then I needed to go actually pay my mortgage. So I got a day job and I was doing that at night. And my day job was at Pivotal Labs, which back in the day was a well-known agile consultancy that specialized in Ruby and Rails applications at the time. child welfare management, which is a really, really complex business domain. And Rails helped us focus on the business logic and not on the incidental complexity of building a large system. And that's when I really got sold on Rails as the easiest and fastest way to get something new up and running. I later became a client at another startup of Pivotal. Then I went back to Pivotal
一个可以构建和销售的测试版。我们处于初创模式。然后我需要去付房租（房贷），所以我找了一份白天的工作，晚上还在做那个。我的白天工作是在 Pivotal Labs，在当时，那是一家知名的敏捷咨询公司，当时专门从事 Ruby 和 Rails 应用程序。儿童福利管理，这是一个非常非常复杂的业务领域。Rails 帮助我们专注于业务逻辑，而不是构建大型系统的附带复杂性。正是在那个时候，我真正认同 Rails 是让新项目启动并运行的最简单、最快的方法。后来我成为了 Pivotal 在另一家初创公司的客户。然后我又回到了 Pivotal
again, where I ran their New York consulting business. And then finally, I worked on Cloud Foundry, which is like, it's like Heroku for enterprises, right? You want your developers to have that ease of pushing an app, but you have your own data center. Like, what do you do? You buy Cloud Foundry and you run it internally. And Cloud Foundry, as it turns out, was originally built by VMware in Ruby.
再次工作，在那里我负责管理他们在纽约的咨询业务。最后，我参与了 Cloud Foundry，它就像是……就像是企业版的 Heroku，对吧？你希望你的开发者拥有推送应用的便捷性，但你又拥有自己的数据中心。那你该怎么办？你购买 Cloud Foundry 并在内部运行它。事实证明，Cloud Foundry 最初是由 VMware 用 Ruby 构建的。
Weird coincidence. It was built in Ruby. But it turns out that Ruby is not great at doing things like handling, at least in 2016, it was not good at handling 10,000 simultaneous network connections, the kind of things that you need to run this big platform as a service. And so then we started selectively rewriting pieces in Go. But for the most part, there were big chunks of Cloud Foundry that today are still in Ruby. And so I ran engineering for Cloud Foundry for about four years too. And then I came to Shopify finally. Ah, nice. Very cool. So I'm trying to do the math here. So you joined Shopify four or five years ago? It was about two and a half years ago. Oh, two and a half years ago. Okay.
奇怪的巧合。它是用 Ruby 构建的。但事实证明，Ruby 不擅长处理诸如处理——至少在 2016 年，它不擅长处理 1,0000 个同时的网络连接，而这些正是运行这种大型平台即服务（PaaS）所需的功能。所以然后我们开始有选择性地用 Go 重写部分代码。但就大部分而言，Cloud Foundry 中有很大一部分直到今天仍然是用 Ruby 编写的。所以我也负责管理 Cloud Foundry 的工程团队大约四年。最后我来到了 Shopify。啊，太棒了。非常酷。所以我在这里试图算一下。所以你是在四五年前加入 Shopify 的？大约是两年半前。哦，两年半前。好的。
Two and a half years ago. Yeah. I was at pivotal for about 12 years total ah really long time really long time yeah that is awesome so pivotal is is is more like targeting developers different than so shopify is more of like a b2c or i guess it is a b2b but it but it has a different sort of customer base. And so was there any shearing effect going from Pivotal to Shopify? What was sort of the biggest differences there? So definitely the biggest differences were, you know, CloudFoundry, we were selling to like the Fortune 100 companies, right? We're selling to like huge financial institutions, huge retail institutions. And Shopify is selling a product to a lot of mom and pop store owners, especially during the pandemic. A lot of mom and pop store owners
两年半前。是的。我在 Pivotal 总共待了大约 12 年，啊，真的好久，真的好久。是的，太棒了。所以 Pivotal 更倾向于面向开发者，和……所以 Shopify 更像是面向 B2C，或者我猜它是 B2B，但它有不同的客户群。所以从 Pivotal 到 Shopify 有没有经历什么阵痛？其中最大的不同是什么？所以最大的不同绝对是，你知道的，CloudFoundry，我们的销售对象是财富 100 强公司，对吧？我们的销售对象是庞大的金融机构、巨大的零售机构。而 Shopify 则是向许多夫妻店店主销售产品，尤其是在疫情期间。许多夫妻店店主
who no longer could open their store and wanted to get online. And Shopify was a really easy way for someone who has inventory and a store and a business model to start selling online. That's what Shopify is really all about. It's trying to make in the same way that a great language will help a developer focus on the business logic that's important. Shopify helps a store owner focus on the business and not on the problems of accounting and how do I get connected to a payment gateway. If someone's not a software developer, they don't want to deal with that part of running an online store. And that's what Shopify takes care of.
无法再开门营业，想要将业务搬到线上。对于拥有库存、店铺和商业模式的人来说，Shopify 是一个非常简单的开始在线销售的方式。这正是 Shopify 的核心所在。它试图做到——就像一门优秀的语言能帮助开发者专注于重要的业务逻辑一样，Shopify 帮助店主专注于业务，而不是会计问题以及如何连接支付网关的烦恼。如果某人不是软件开发者，他们就不想处理运营在线商店的这部分工作。而这正是 Shopify 负责解决的。
Got it. That makes sense. So when you joined Shopify, there must be a legacy of Ruby at Shopify for it to really pique your interest. There is. So Toby is our CEO. He's only got one name. He's like Madonna. Toby, Toby Lutke. He is an old school Rubyist himself. And he, in fact, was one of the early collaborators on the Rails framework, which is the big web framework in the Ruby community. So he started Shopify. He was like the second person ever to use Rails, right? He and David Hansen were friends and he started using it to build Shopify.
明白了。这说得通。所以当你加入 Shopify 时，Shopify 必然有着 Ruby 的历史传承，这才会真正激起你的兴趣。确实如此。我们的 CEO 是 Toby。他只有一个名字。他就像麦当娜一样。Toby，Toby Lutke。他本人就是一个老派的 Ruby 开发者。事实上，他是 Rails 框架（Ruby 社区中大型的网络框架）早期合作者之一。所以他创办了 Shopify。他可以说是历史上第二早使用 Rails 的人，对吧？他和 David Hansen 是朋友，他开始用它来构建 Shopify。
And I think he feels very strongly, if you asked him, he would tell you that he feels strongly that Shopify was successful because he was able to move so quickly, right? He was able to get to production faster than his competitors. And there were a couple of instances that we have an internal podcast at Shopify where he talks about this. And he said that there were a couple of occasions where Shopify was close to going out of business. And the fact that he was able to ship new features and get new customers in a matter of weeks made a real fundamental difference in whether Shopify was going to make it through those tough times. And since then, we've, of course,
而且我认为他坚信，如果你去问他，他会告诉你，他坚信 Shopify 的成功是因为他能够行动得如此迅速，对吧？他能够比竞争对手更快地投入生产。我们有几个例子——我们在 Shopify 内部有一个播客，他在节目中谈到了这一点。他说，有几次 Shopify 险些倒闭。而他能够在几周内发布新功能并吸引新客户的事实，对于 Shopify 是否能度过那些艰难时期起到了真正根本性的作用。从那以后，我们当然
IPO'd and now we're a multi-billion dollar company. So it's all in the past. But I think he credits Ruby and Rails with a lot of Shopify success. And so we have a very strong opinion internally that that's the default stack we use. Cool. That makes a ton of sense. Yeah, I have not a counter example, but a correlated example where we were trying to build a while ago at another company. We were trying to build a like a new another company, we were trying to build a, like a new product, a new area for the company. And because so much was done in Java, they said,
已经 IPO 了，现在我们是一家价值数十亿美元的公司。所以这一切都已成为过去。但我认为他将 Shopify 的巨大成功归功于Ruby 和 Rails。因此，我们在内部有一个非常坚定的观点，即那是我们使用的默认技术栈。酷。这非常合乎情理。是的，我没有反例，但有一个相关的例子，我们以前在另一家公司试图构建一个……我们在尝试构建一个……另一家公司，我们试图构建一个……新产品，公司的一个新领域。因为大部分工作都是用 Java 完成的，他们说：
we'll write the whole thing in Java. And I actually, and this is a bit of my personal, like anecdotal opinion here, take it with a grain of salt, but I feel like Java really caused the product to slow down, the product development. And part of it was not, it wasn't just that it was in Java, but it was also that it was hooked into all these other systems that were written in all sorts of different languages. And so they all had different APIs. Oh, there isn't a Java API for this backend. So now we're all just sitting on our hands. And I think that's one of the reasons why that project just couldn't get off the ground is that it couldn't move fast enough. So we'll
我们要用 Java 把整个东西重写一遍。而且我实际上——这有点我个人的、随意的看法，大家姑妄听之——但我感觉 Java 确实导致产品开发速度变慢了。部分原因不仅在于它是用 Java 写的，还在于它与所有其他用各种不同语言编写的系统挂钩。所以它们都有不同的 API。哦，这个后端没有 Java API。所以现在我们只能大眼瞪小眼地干坐着。我认为这就是该项目无法起步的原因之一，因为它无法足够快地推进。所以我们
definitely talk about, you mentioned several times agility with Ruby and Rails. We'll definitely cover that, but we'll put a bookmark in it for now and switch gears and talk to Evan. Evan, why don't you tell us what your background is and what your sort of connection is with Ruby? Sure. So my story starts in the first tech bubble, the bursting of the first tech bubble. So I graduated from college in 2002, which was the uniformly known as the worst possible time to get a programming job. Uh, like every, every single place was firing. No place was hiring. I remember that same time I was in undergrad, graduated a little bit after you in 2004. And I remember my, uh, my dad basically shaking his head saying, I told you,
绝对会谈到——你多次提到 Ruby 和 Rails 的敏捷性。我们肯定会讨论这一点，但目前我们先把它搁置一下，转换话题跟 Evan 聊聊。Evan，能跟我们讲讲你的背景以及你与 Ruby 的渊源吗？当然。我的故事始于第一次科技泡沫破裂之时。所以我于 2002 年大学毕业，这一年被普遍认为是找编程工作的最糟糕的时期。像……每一个地方都在裁员。没有地方在招人。我记得大约在那个时候，我是本科生，在你毕业后不久的 2004 年毕业。我记得我……
you should have got a math degree. You went and got a CS degree. Look at you now. I mean, you were right in the end, but at that time, it was tough. So it was 2002. I had just graduated. I moved to Seattle. My then girlfriend, now wife, and I moved to Seattle. She was starting her master's program. And I'm not a great student, I had no interest in continuing on with higher education. So I was like, I'm just gonna figure it out. And so I tried to get a job couldn't get a job, ended up getting a job with a local ISP. It was a three person ISP. And I basically put sat like 802.11 not be so pre B standard 802.11 dishes on people's roofs for this ISP because it was a wireless ISP. And so I would spend afternoons on roofs, retirement buildings on roofs,
我爸爸基本上摇着头对我说：“我早就告诉你，你应该去拿个数学学位。你非要去拿个计算机科学学位。看看你现在这样。”我的意思是，你最后是对的，但当时确实很难。所以那是 2002 年。我刚毕业。我搬到了 Seattle（西雅图）。我当时的红颜知己、现在的妻子和我搬到了西雅图。她当时要开始读硕士项目。而我不是个好学生，我对继续接受高等教育毫无兴趣。所以我当时想：“我只能自己摸索了。”所以我试着找工作，但找不到工作，最后在当地一家 ISP（互联网服务提供商）找到了一份工作。那是一家只有三个人的 ISP。我基本上负责为这家 ISP 在人们的屋顶上安装 802.11 b 之前的标准（802.11非b标准）的无线天线，因为那是一家无线 ISP。所以我整个下午都在屋顶上度过，在养老院的屋顶上，
lots of roofs. I've seen so many of the roofs of Seattle. I should have started a scrapbook in retrospect, so many roofs. So I'm at this job, and I don't want to be do I wanted to be a programmer, like that was what I had done. I'd actually done open source in college. I had worked on some programming language stuff in college, because it was really interesting to me. But now I didn't have any opportunity for that. But when I moved to Seattle, I was very active in a specific IRC channel from college and so and one of the people in the IRC channel actually was like hey I'm writing this really interesting thing and I found he he was also in Seattle coincidentally this guy even though we'd been talking for years and uh he
在无数的屋顶上。我见过太多西雅图的屋顶了。回想起来，我真该建一本剪贴簿，有那么多的屋顶。所以我在做这份工作，但我不想干这个。我想成为一名程序员，那正是我以前做过的事。我在大学里其实做过开源。我在大学里做过一些编程语言方面的工作，因为我对这很感兴趣。但现在我没有这方面的机会了。不过当我搬到西雅图时，我在大学的一个特定 IRC 频道里非常活跃，然后……IRC 频道里的一个人实际上说：“嘿，我在写一个非常有趣的东西，”我发现他——巧合的是，他也住在西雅图，尽管我们已经聊了好几年了，而且……
was like hey I'm writing this thing and um it's in this programming language called Ruby and I was like hi I'd never heard of that and so I went to go look at it and it took me about a couple of weeks before I was like, because I had done Perl and PHP almost exclusive, well, and C++ and C at that point in time, but on the sort of Ruby-ish side of things, PHP and Perl. And so it took me a while to get the feel for Ruby. But once I did, I was like, oh, this is great. I like this a lot better than the stuff for Ruby. But once I did, I was like, oh, this is great. I like this
他当时说：“嘿，我在写一个东西，它是用一门叫做 Ruby 的编程语言写的。”我说：“嗨，我从没听说过那个。”所以我去了解了一下，大概花了几个星期的时间，因为我几乎只用过 Perl 和 PHP（好吧，当时还用过 C++ 和 C，但在偏向 Ruby 的技术栈方面，用的是 PHP 和 Perl）。所以我花了点时间才找到 Ruby 的手感。但一旦上手，我就觉得：“哦，太棒了。我比以前……我非常喜欢这个。”但在上手之后，我就觉得：“哦，太棒了。我比以前用的那些东西
a lot better than the stuff that I've been doing before. It's much more, it's easy to express what I want. I'm not fighting with pearl sigils, which is a little symbol you put at the beginning all the time. I liked it a lot. I ended up getting involved with Ruby and then not seeing that RubyConf, which was like the Ruby conference that started in 2000, I actually missed it by a week. It was in Seattle. It was down the block from me. Didn't go because I didn't realize. I literally was just like, oh yeah, Ruby, that's a cool thing. Oh, the conference was here last week. It was pretty amusing. But I did get involved with some other Ruby people in Seattle, Ryan Davis and Eric Hodel. And we started the first, it's hard to say if it's the first, but effectively people used to call it the first Ruby user group, Seattle RB.
喜欢太多了。它要好得多，能轻松表达我的意愿。我不用跟 Perl 的 sigil（你一直放在开头的小符号）搏斗了。我非常喜欢它。我最终开始参与 Ruby，然后……没有看到 RubyConf，那是 2000 年开始的 Ruby 会议，我其实跟它擦肩而过，就差了一个星期。它就在西雅图举行。离我住的地方只有几个街区。没去是因为我当时没意识到。我字面上的反应就是：“哦，对哦，Ruby，那是个挺酷的东西。哦，会议上周刚结束。”挺搞笑的。但我确实跟西雅图的其他一些 Ruby 爱好者——Ryan Davis 和 Eric Hodel——建立起了联系，我们成立了第一家……很难说是不是第一家，但人们过去常常称之为第一个 Ruby 用户组：Seattle.rb。
And it was just the three of us. We used to meet at Ryan's work and just putz around and do random talk about things. We ended up getting, like I remember one time, we got a review copy of the Pickaxe book, which is like the canonical, the original reference book for Ruby that Dave Thomas wrote. And we did a review of that to set Dave notes because I think Ryan knew him at the time. Anyway, so that's how
当时只有我们三个人。我们经常在 Ryan 的工作地点见面，四处瞎搞，随便聊聊各种事情。我们最终拿到了……我记得有一次，我们拿到了一本《Pickaxe》（镐头书）的预览版，那是 Dave Thomas 写的关于 Ruby 的规范性、最初的参考书。我们对它进行了审阅，给 Dave 提供意见，因为我猜 Ryan 当时认识他。不管怎样，这就是
it started so you were you're working for this uh ISP you're you're mounting uh dishes wi-fi dishes on roofs and but but uh but you were involved in a lot of these kind of uh social groups and and and sort of you know building up this Ruby ecosystem. And yeah, that's actually a testament, you know, I think where there's so many companies talking about this looming recession. I don't know what's going to happen. Nobody really does. But something to sort of foreshadow or some foresight based on your experience is to, you know, even if the job market does contract to get difficult to there's always
一切开始的地方。所以你当时在为这家 ISP 工作，你在屋顶上安装天线、Wi-Fi 天线，但是……但是你参与了许多这种……社交群体，并且在建立这个 Ruby 生态系统。是的，这实际上是一个证明，你知道的，我认为现在有那么多公司在谈论即将来临的经济衰退。我不知道会发生什么。没有人真正知道。但根据你的经验，可以预示或提供一些远见的是（也就是）：即使就业市场确实收缩并变得困难，作为个体，你总能做很多事情，你可以去参加那么多不同的会议，结识那么多不同的人。随着我们经历这场……这里的这种微小低谷期，这将会变得越来越重要。是的，我的意思是，经济衰退影响的是经济和货币政策，而不是人们的热情或兴趣。没错。没错。
so much that you can do, you know, as an individual, there's so many different conventions you can go to people you can meet. And that is going to be more and more important. We sort of, you know, go through this, like kind of small lull here. Yeah, I mean, recessions affect the economies of monetary policy, not people's enthusiasm or interest. Right. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Like, yeah, at the time it was impossible to get a Ruby job. Well, at the time, Ruby jobs did not exist. It was not a thing. Matt's had only begun Ruby in 1996 and it didn't, it only lived on his laptop for the first couple of years anyway.
是的。对，当时要想找一份 Ruby 工作是不可能的。好吧，当时 Ruby 的工作根本就不存在。根本没这回事。Matz 是在 1996 年才开始搞 Ruby 的，而且在头几年里，它也只存在于他的笔记本电脑上。
And so we're talking 2002 ish timeframe, maybe 2003, a little bit now. And Dave Thomas, the guy who wrote the pickaxe book was, is kind of credited with bringing Ruby to the English speaking world. Matt's is Japanese. Dave has a great story. I can't remember the exact details, so I'll probably butcher it. But effectively, he saw Ruby, he saw some of the original documentation, he was getting into technical book publishing, and he wrote the first English version of the pickaxe book, the root, we call it the pickaxe books, it has a pickaxe on the
所以我们谈论的是 2002 年左右的时间框架，也许是 2003 年，现在稍微久远一点了。而 Dave Thomas（写了那本镐头书的人）被认为是将 Ruby 带入英语世界的人。Matz 是日本人。Dave 有个很棒的故事。我记不清具体细节了，所以可能会讲得走样。但基本上，他看到了 Ruby，看到了部分最初的文档，他当时正涉足技术图书出版，并编写了第一本英文版的镐头书——我们管它叫镐头书，因为它的封面上一把镐头。
cover. And so he wrote the original version of that that basically was the only guide to Ruby that was written in Japanese. And I think, so I'll fast forward a little bit. I ended up stumbling into another job accidentally, working as the Windows IT administrator, which was better than putting dishes on roofs. So I went to go do that. And then I, but I still wanted to be programming. And so I started just it was a startup in Seattle, I started attending all the engineering meetings, they started, they had a meeting where they were like, hey, like, we want to we want to redo the back end for this thing, because it's not working very well. It's really cobbled together,
所以他写了最初的版本，基本上那是唯一用日语以外语言编写的 Ruby 指南。我想——所以我快进一点。我后来意外地跌跌撞撞地找到了另一份工作，担任 Windows IT 管理员，这比在屋顶上装天线要好。所以我去做了那个。然后我……但我仍然想编程。所以我开始只是——那是西雅图的一家初创公司，我开始参加所有的工程会议。他们开始……他们开了一个会，会上他们说：“嘿，我们想重做这个东西的后端，因为它运行得不是很好。它拼凑得太厉害了，
we want to actually use like, basically it was like sort of a Linux system administration slash programming project. And I was like, I am very interested in this. If no one else has, I've actually done this before because I'd done it in college. I will, I'd be happy to take this on. And they're like, sure. I was, again, I was still the Windows IT admin. And so I was doing the Windows IT administration, keeping the mail server up, making sure people could log in, and writing this new backend. And when I was writing this new backend, I was like, this is sort of what you were talking about earlier. Nobody was telling me anything. They were just, get it done.
我们实际上想用……基本上这就像是一个 Linux 系统管理加编程的项目。”然后我想：“我对这个非常感兴趣。如果其他人没有……我以前其实做过这个，因为我在大学里做过。我很乐意接手这个。”他们说：“没问题。”我当时还是——我仍然是 Windows IT 管理员。所以我当时一边做 Windows IT 管理，维护邮件服务器，确保人们能够登录，一边在编写这个新后端。而当我写这个新后端的时候，我就想——这有点像你刚才说的。没有人告诉我任何事。他们只是说：“把它搞定。
We just need a thing. And I was like, great. I'm going to write it in Ruby because that was way more interesting than writing it in anything else at the time. So I started writing it in anything else at the time. So I started writing it in Ruby. I wrote this amazing gateway so that PHP could call Ruby methods on the same machine because all the front end people were writing PHP. It was great. It was an insane system. PHP, Ruby, Interop. Yeah. It's somewhere out there. It might not be on the internet even. Anyway, so I worked there for a while. Ended up leaving a couple of years. Oh, like that, they got built up.
我们只需要一个东西。”我就想：“太棒了。我要用 Ruby 来写它，因为在当时，这比用其他任何语言写都要有趣得多。”所以我开始用其他任何语言来写它——不，我开始用 Ruby 来写它。我写了一个神奇的网关，以便 PHP 可以在同一台机器上调用 Ruby 方法，因为所有的前端人员都在写 PHP。太棒了。这是一个疯狂的系统。PHP 和 Ruby 互操作。是的。它可能在某个地方。甚至可能不在互联网上。不管怎样，我在那里工作了一段时间。几年后离职了……哦，就像那样，业务做起来了。
We ended up doing a lot of Ruby at that company. I ended up leaving and then going to another small startup for about six months, basically writing a Rails app. And then in 2006, that was in 2000. That was like the beginning of 2006. In 2007, I was still living in Seattle, it's gonna move down to LA, I ended up going to RailsConf that year. This is another sort of diatribe, we'll keep it short, which is, I have weird programming interests. I had been writing a new version of Ruby, the programming language, the interpreter. So Ruby, as a as any
我们在那家公司最终做了很多 Ruby。我后来离职了，去了一家小型初创公司大约六个月，基本上就是写一个 Rails 应用。然后在 2006 年——那是 2000 年。那是 2006 年初。在 2007 年，我仍然住在西雅图，即将搬去洛杉矶，我那年去了 RailsConf。这是另一个长篇大论，我们长话短说，就是：我有奇怪的编程兴趣。我一直在编写新版本的 Ruby，即这门编程语言的解释器。所以 Ruby 作为任何
kind of dynamic language is just a program that reads other programs and runs them, right? It's like a chef that's running a recipe, but the program is the chef. And so I had all these interests in how to make Ruby better, and I had started writing my own version of the actual interpreter, the engine to run Ruby programs and i had been doing that for a year and a half two years at that point and i had i had a thing that was interesting um i ended up giving a little talk about it at rails conf which is in portland that year i drove down from seattle to portland to talk about it and the cto of engine, who was an early Rails hosting company, saw my talk and he's like, I think your thing's cool. Tom Marnini is his name, CTO.
类型的动态语言，本质上只是一个读取其他程序并运行它们的程序，对吧？它就像一个按照食谱做菜的厨师，但这个程序本身就是厨师。所以我对如何改进 Ruby 产生了种种兴趣，我开始编写自己的实际解释器版本——即运行 Ruby 程序的引擎——当时我已经搞了一年半到两年了。我当时做出了一个挺有意思的东西。我最终在当年的波特兰 RailsConf 上做了一个小型演讲。我从西雅图开车到波特兰去讲这个，Engine Yard（当时是一个早期的 Rails 托管公司）的 CTO 看了我的演讲，他说：“我觉得你的东西很酷。”Tom Mornini 是他的名字，CTO。
I think your thing is really cool. Would you be interested in coming and working for Engine Yard? And we'll let you work on this thing. And I was like, this is the dream. Oh, that's amazing. This is the dream, right? Like someone wants to pay me to work on my open source project. So I said yes as fast as I could. And then I did that for five years. I just worked on my own, well, an open source Ruby implementation for about five years called Rubinius. And yeah, that was super intense. There's lots of stories about that.
“我觉得你的东西真的很酷。你有没有兴趣来 Engine Yard 工作？我们会让你继续搞这个东西。”当时我想：这就是梦想啊。哦，太棒了。这就是梦想，对吧？有人愿意付钱让我去搞我的开源项目。所以我以最快的速度说“我愿意”。然后我在那里干了五年。我专门研究我自己的——嗯，一个开源的 Ruby 实现，大概干了五年，名叫 Rubinius。是的，那真是超级激烈。有很多关于那段经历的故事。
Where did Rubinius go? Like did parts of it get folded into Ruby or are folks still using it? Well, it had a lot of contributions. I would say that a big portion of the stuff that we wrote, it lives out on the internet, but it's probably not in heavy usage. Probably there's a couple of people who still use it for random things. What ended up happening was I started writing Rubinius when Ruby was at version 1.8.2. That was in 2006. And at that time, Ruby was actually moving pretty slowly in terms of the API, the functionality, all that kind of stuff. And so it made it easy if I was like somebody's trying to come in and being like, I want to implement this API, which is just the program languages API. And it was about a year after that or so that the mats and the Ruby core team really started to speed things up.
Rubinius 后来去哪了？它的某些部分被合并到 Ruby 里了吗，还是人们还在使用它？嗯，它有很多贡献。我想说，我们编写的大部分代码都在互联网上流传，但可能没有处于高强度使用中。可能还有几个人出于各种随机目的在使用它。最终发生的情况是，我开始编写 Rubinius 时，Ruby 的版本是 1.8.2。那是在 2006 年。当时，就 API、功能以及所有这些东西而言，Ruby 的发展速度其实相当缓慢。所以这让我很容易去应付，如果有人进来并说：“我想实现这个 API”，而这只是编程语言的 API。大约在那之后的一两年，Matz 和 Ruby 核心团队真正开始加快步伐。
And it only got faster and faster over the next couple of years. And it's hard. It's very hard to write a thing that's chasing something else and you don't have any control over it. You're just chasing this other thing. And after about five years of working on it, I was personally like, I want to be more in control of my own destiny. Like every time, like every day I was coming in and being like, what crazy weird API do I have to implement today that I don't want to? And that's not fun as a job. I ended up leaving there and going to LivingSocial. But yeah, that was that bit. Oh, interesting. I think there's one other thing I want to throw in here
在接下来的几年里，它的发展速度越来越快。这很难。追赶一个你无法控制且在不断变化的东西是非常难的。你只是在追赶另一个东西。在为此工作了五年之后，我个人觉得：我想要更多地掌控自己的命运。就像每天我去上班时都在想：今天我又得实现什么我根本不想实现的疯狂而怪异的 API？作为一份工作，这可一点都不好玩。我最终选择离职，去了 LivingSocial。但总之，那就是那段经历。哦，有意思。我想在这里顺便提另一件事，
while we're talking about Rubinius. If you look at Ruby on the decades-long timescale, one of the, I think, most important outcomes from the Rubinius project was actually RubySpec, which is the specification for Ruby. It was an executable, it was tests, right? They were an executable specification for Ruby because the original Ruby interpreter, it was just like, well, it behaves how it behaves. Like it's the only Ruby interpreter. And so there were a lot of edge cases that were kind of undefined behavior. And as part of the Rubinius project, that Ruby spec project is actually still alive and kicking today and unifies all the Ruby interpretations because there's like JRuby,
我们在谈论 Rubinius 时。如果你以长达几十年的时间尺度来看 Ruby，我认为 Rubinius 项目最最重要的成果之一，实际上是 RubySpec，也就是 Ruby 的规范。它是一个可执行的测试，对吧？它们是 Ruby 的可执行规范，因为最初的 Ruby 解释器就是那种“它表现成怎样就怎样”的状态。它是唯一的 Ruby 解释器。所以有很多边缘情况可以说是未定义行为。作为 Rubinius 项目的一部分，那个 Ruby spec 项目至今依然生机勃勃，并且统一了所有的 Ruby 实现，因为有诸如 JRuby（
which is built on the JVM, and there's TruffleRuby, which is built on GraalVM, as well as Ruby and Rubinius and a few others that are all using Ruby spec as the de facto standard for the Ruby language now. I think that that is a really important outcome as well. Yeah, that totally makes sense. I think the you know, the parallel that comes to my mind is io.js, right? So Node had some deficiencies. So I think it was maybe the original Node author. I don't actually remember. I might be getting that wrong. But somebody wrote EO. And long story short, EO and Node merged later on. And so a lot of the best parts of EO made it into Node. And so I think, yeah, it sounds like something similar that
构建在 JVM 之上），以及构建在 GraalVM 之上的 TruffleRuby，还有 Ruby 和 Rubinius 以及其他一些解释器，它们现在都将 Ruby spec 作为 Ruby 语言的事实标准。我认为这也是一个非常重要的成果。是的，这完全说得通。我想……我脑海中浮现的平行案例是 io.js，对吧？所以 Node 当时存在一些缺陷。所以我想那可能是最初的 Node 作者。我其实记不清了。我可能记错了。但有人编写了 io。长话短说，io 和 Node 后来合并了。所以 io 的许多最佳部分都进入了 Node 中。所以我想，是的，听起来类似于这里发生的事情，
happened here where as a consequence of Rubinius, you have this specification for the language, and that created a huge harmony among all these different interpreters and push the language forward. Yeah. One of the most interesting things, the Ruby community is a, it's a by-product of, there's a, there's a saying in the Ruby community called Minaswan, which is maths is nice. So we are nice. And that there's a big, there's a big, it seems like a thing that people wouldn't actually say, but people, people mention it all the time. It's really part of the ethos of the Ruby community. The Ruby community has spread its wings as it's gotten bigger in time. And I think one of the most interesting things is that, this is my skewed perception, but my perception is that the Ruby community is one of the first communities that really took TDD, test-driven development, to heart. It existed mostly from
由于 Rubinius 的存在，你拥有了这个语言规范，这在所有这些不同的解释器之间创造了巨大的和谐，并推动了该语言的发展。是的。最有趣的事情之一是，Ruby 社区是……它是……Ruby 社区中有一句名言叫作“Minaswan”，意思是 Matz is nice. So we are nice（Matz 人很好，所以我们也很好）。这是一个很大的……人们可能觉得大家不会真的挂在嘴边，但人们经常提到它。它确实是 Ruby 社区精神 ethos 的一部分。随着时间推移，Ruby 社区在不断壮大，羽翼渐丰。我认为最有趣的事情之一是——这是我带偏见的看法，但我的看法是——Ruby 社区是最早真正将 TDD（测试驱动开发）铭记于心的社区之一。它主要诞生于
Kent Beck in the Smalltalk world, but there isn't that many Smalltalk developers. And a lot of the Smalltalk developers ended up in Ruby or were influenced into Ruby at various times. And I remember being exposed to TDD in 2002, 2003, when nobody was doing it. And that was a big impact on Rubinius writing RubySpec. Brian Shirai, who was like the second or third person to work on Rubinius with me, started that specifically because it was like, hey, we got to know what we're doing. We got to write some tests. We got to write specification for this thing.
Smalltalk 世界的 Kent Beck，但 Smalltalk 开发者并没有那么多。而且许多 Smalltalk 开发者最终都转到了 Ruby，或者在不同时期受到了 Ruby 的影响。我记得在 2002、2003 年左右接触过 TDD，当时根本没人这么做。这对 Rubinius 编写 RubySpec 产生了巨大影响。Brian Shirai（他是和我一起从事 Rubinius 工作的第二或第三个人）专门发起这个项目，是因为当时的想法是：“嘿，我们必须知道自己在做什么。我们必须编写一些测试。我们必须为这个东西编写规范。”
And still to this day has a huge impact. So Ruby spec ended up being adopted into the mainline Ruby interpreter. They still write those specs. One of the big things about Rubinius was I tried to write all of or as much of the Ruby API in Ruby itself. So you could go and look at the implementation of array and it would be written in ruby for instance that code made its way over to truffle ruby which is a very specialized implementation of ruby and has evolved since then they have they've edited it's they you know they're perfectly much more owned by them at this point but um it's kind of seeded itself in different ways very cool so after Rubinius, at that point,
直到今天它依然有着巨大的影响。所以 Ruby spec 最终被主线 Ruby 解释器所采纳。他们现在仍在编写这些规范。关于 Rubinius 的一大重点是，我试图用 Ruby 自身编写全部或尽可能多的 Ruby API。所以你可以去查看 array（数组）的实现，它是用 Ruby 编写的。举个例子，这段代码后来被引入到了 TruffleRuby 中，这是一个高度专门化的 Ruby 实现，并从那时起不断演进。他们对它进行了编辑、修改，你知道的，到了现在，它在很大程度上已经由他们自己掌控了，但……它以不同的方式播下了种子。非常酷。所以在 Rubinius 之后，
what's the sort of link between that and and Ruby gems, which is, which is what your focus is on now? What's the path there? Yeah, so I had been going, I started going to Ruby conferences in 2005, which was in San Diego, I got to, I got to watch the first release of Rails be released. They released it at RubyConf, which is just Toby and David in the front of the room releasing it. It was very interesting. So I ended up starting going to Ruby conferences then. And they were great. I was in the community. I was super interested in it. And I kind of just kept going. As my second job or whatever in this story showed, I fall into system administration jobs fairly regularly. Tasks maybe is probably the right word, rather than actual jobs. And in 2011, there was a thing called RubyForge, which was a hosting platform that was meant to,
那个阶段与 RubyGems 之间有什么联系？RubyGems 正是你现在关注的重点。那条路径是怎样的？是的，我一直在去——我从 2005 年开始去参加 Ruby 会议，那是在圣迭戈，我得以观看了 Rails 的首次发布。他们在 RubyConf 上发布了它，当时只有 Toby 和 David 在房间前台发布它。非常有趣。所以我从那时起开始去参加 Ruby 会议。它们棒极了。我融入了这个社区。我对它超级感兴趣。然后我就一直坚持下去了。正如我在这段故事中的第二份工作所显示的那样，我相当规律地陷入系统管理工作中。
this is pre-GitHub. So it started pre-GitHub. It was basically a place for people to store their Ruby code, right? That was really what it was for. And it was sort of an alternative to SourceForge, which some of your audiences heard of and some of your audiences has not. It was a sort of a precursor for where to store your code on the internet. Yeah, SourceForge, if you've ever needed an old library and you end up clicking on 14 ads and you don't actually get the zip file of the library, that was SourceForge. That was SourceForge, yeah. Oh, man, you could do a three-hour thing about the evolution of SourceForge as well. So there was RubyForge, which really just ran.
也许用“任务（Task）”这个词比“真正的工作”更贴切。而在 2011 年，有一个叫作 RubyForge 的东西，它是一个托管平台，旨在……这是在 GitHub 之前。所以它诞生于 GitHub 之前。它基本上是人们存储 Ruby 代码的地方，对吧？这才是它的真正用途。它算是 SourceForge 的替代品，你们的一些听众听说过，一些听众没听说过。它是互联网上存储代码的先驱。是的，SourceForge，如果你曾经需要一个旧库，结果不得不点击 14 个广告却根本没有下载到该库的 zip 文件，那就是 SourceForge。那就是 SourceForge，没错。哦，天哪，关于 SourceForge 的演变，你完全可以讲上整整三个小时。所以当时有 RubyForge，它实际上运行着……
There was a package called GForge, which was just like you could run your own SourceForge-like thing. And so there was a thing called a couple of Ruby developers ran a thing called Ruby forge, just ruby forge.org, people would upload their things. And then in 2007, or so I'd have to go back and check if it was 2006, seven or eight, I can't remember a couple of Ruby developers, Chad Fowler and David Black, who are all directors at Ruby Central, which is the nonprofit that puts on the conference, start basically at a conference. We're like, we need our own like Java jar like thing. So let's start, let's write one. And so they basically wrote Ruby gems. The first version was a couple of weeks, maybe probably the first version was probably
有一个叫作 GForge 的软件包，你基本上可以运行你自己的类似于 SourceForge 的东西。所以有一群 Ruby 开发者运行了一个名为 RubyForge 的东西，就是 rubyforge.org，人们会把他们的东西上传到那里。然后在 2007 年左右——我得去查查到底是 2006、2007 还是 2008 年，我记不清了——几位 Ruby 开发者，Chad Fowler 和 David Black，他们都是 Ruby Central（举办该会议的非营利组织）的董事，基本上在一次会议上……我们当时觉得：我们需要自己的类似 Java jar 包那样的东西。所以让我们开始吧，让我们写一个。于是他们基本上编写了 RubyGems。第一个版本花了几个星期，可能第一个版本大概
at the conference. So within a couple of days, and then they wired in the ability to start to to handle Ruby gems inside RubyForge. So if you uploaded a gem file to RubyForge, it would be available for you to do gem install. That was the first version of RubyGems. So fast forward again back to 2011, I got wind that they were still running RubyForge. Well, I knew they were still running RubyForge and that there was only one person who was this administrator for this whole system. And I was like, that's not cool. That's not fair. And I was like, that's not I'm going to reach out and I'm going to say, like, I'm happy to help you out run this thing. And so I reached out just to say, like, do you need to have another hand, another person who can basically help you on call, because the guy who was running it is a wonderful guy, but it was not fair to him to basically be doing this whole thing. So that's how I got involved with Ruby gems. Originally, it was basically I'm going to help out run. Well, a little bit, I got involved with Ruby, Ruby gems software a little bit earlier
在会议上。所以短短几天内，他们就加上了在 RubyForge 内部处理 Ruby gem 的功能。因此，如果你把 gem 文件上传到 RubyForge，就可以直接用 gem install 安装它。这就是 RubyGems 的第一个版本。快进到 2011 年，我听说他们还在运行 RubyForge。其实我知道他们还在运行 RubyForge，而且整个系统只有一个管理员。当时我觉得，这不太酷。这很不公平。我当时想，我要去联系他们，说我很乐于帮他们维护这个系统。所以我联系他们只是想问问：需不需要多一个人，多一个基本上能随叫随到的人？因为负责维护的那位仁兄是个非常好的人，但让他一个人包揽所有活，对太不公平了。这就是我参与 RubyGems 的契机。最初的想法很简单，就是去帮忙维护。不过，其实我接触 Ruby、RubyGems 软件的时间稍微要比这
than that. But the bulk of it was really the stuff we're talking about today is really helping out run the server, debug some crazy things, and then, yeah, that was how it began. So what is it like going to a language conference? So let's say you're a college student. You really love, I'm just going to pick a language. You really love Ruby. Maybe you've made pick a language, you really love Ruby, maybe you've made a few commits to the sort of core, you know, Ruby interpreter or other parts
更早一些。但其中最大部分的工作，也就是我们今天讨论的重点，确实是帮忙维护服务器、调试一些奇怪的问题，然后，是的，一切就是这样开始的。那么，参加编程语言大会是什么体验呢？假设你是一名大学生。你非常热爱——我随便举个语言——你非常热爱 Ruby。也许你已经（随便挑门语言吧）你非常热爱 Ruby，也许你已经为核心（你知道的，Ruby 解释器）或其他部分
of the ecosystem. But you just love programming in Ruby, you know, is like, what would someone like that get out of a conference? How would you recommend getting the most out of a conference if it's your first time? What's that whole thing like? I've been to, personally, I've been to a lot of conferences, but admittedly, I've never been to a programming language conference. It's on my bucket list. But you kind of described to us all what that is like and what you would expect to see there and how to really have an effective time there. Let me take a whack at answering this real quick. So my strong opinion here is that there's a spectrum of conferences and there's like some conferences are small. Like I used to organize, co-organize the Gotham Ruby conference
的代码贡献过几次提交。但你就是喜欢用 Ruby 编程，你会想，像这样的人从会议中能收获什么？如果是第一次参加会议，你有什么建议能让收获最大化？那种体验到底是怎么样的？就我个人而言，我去过很多会议，但必须承认，我从来没有去过编程语言大会。这在我的愿望清单上。不过你可以给我们大家描述一下那是什么样的体验，你在那里期望看到什么，以及如何才能在那里度过一段高效的时光吗？让我来简单试着回答一下这个问题。我非常坚定的一个观点是，会议其实是有不同类型和规模的。有些会议很小。比如我过去常在
in New York City, which was one day, one track, very intimate conference. So everyone had the same shared experience. You show up, you sit next to somebody, you get to know them, you go to lunch, you come back, there's some more talks, then we'd go on a boat and have dinner. And it was great. I think that for me was my introduction to software language conference. It helps you build a local network of people, and there's usually a really great mix of introductory talks as well as some more advanced talks. And then I think once you get comfortable and you go
纽约市组织、联合组织 Gotham Ruby 会议，那是一个为期一天、只有单轨议程的非常私密的会议。所以每个人都有共同的体验。你来到现场，坐在某个人旁边，开始认识彼此，一起去吃午餐，然后回来听更多的演讲，接着我们会坐船出海吃晚餐。感觉棒极了。对我来说，那这就是我参加软件语言会议的启蒙。它能帮你建立一个本地的人脉网络，而且通常既有非常棒的入门演讲，也有一些更高级的进阶演讲。然后我想，一旦你适应了并且参加过
to one or two of those, then maybe you want to say, okay, I'm going to get on a plane, and I'm going to go to a bigger conference, and maybe I go to a three-day Ruby conference in New Orleans, which was my big experience at my first big, a bigger conference. And maybe I go to like a three-day Ruby conference in New Orleans, which was like my big experience at my first big, huge software conference. And like, that's like a really big deal.
一两次这种会议，也许你就会想：“好吧，我要坐飞机去参加一个规模更大的会议，也许去新奥尔良参加为期三天的 Ruby 会议。”那是我第一次参加大型软件会议的大好经历。也许我会去新奥尔良参加一个为期三天的 Ruby 会议，那就像是我第一次参加的大型、超大型软件会议的重大经历。那种感觉真的很了不起。
And then the social network that you've built locally can help you there. But again, there's usually a great mix of both introductory and more advanced talks at all of these conferences. So you can kind of pick and choose which ones you're interested in and want to pay attention to. And you get to talk to the speakers afterwards. And it's as much about the social network you're building as it is about what you're learning inside any individual talk for me.
然后你在本地建立的社交网络就能在那儿帮到你。不过话说回来，所有这些会议通常都兼具入门和高级演讲，搭配得非常好。所以你可以根据自己的兴趣挑选想关注的内容。演讲结束后你还可以和他们交流。对我而言，建立社交网络和你在任何单个演讲中学到的东西同样重要。
I don't know, Evan, what's your experience been? Yeah, I, the background, I didn't give this at the beginning, but like I helped run RubyConf and RailsConf for about 10 years. And so I have like, there's three different styles of programming language event, I recall that. The first, like Mike was talking about, is a seminar. That's really the way to think about it, right? Which is basically, you're going to show up, you're going to all sit in the same room, you're going to all watch the same talks, you're going to find out about interesting things that you didn't know that you were interested in, or and maybe they're going
我不知道，埃文，你的经历是怎样的？是的，背景方面，我开头没提，但我曾帮忙运营 RubyConf 和 RailsConf 大约 10 年时间。所以我记得大概有三种不同风格的编程语言活动。第一种，就像迈克刚才说的，是研讨会。这确实是思考它的方式，对吧？也就是说，基本上，你会出现在现场，大家坐在同一个房间里，听同样的演讲，了解一些你以前不知道自己会感兴趣的有趣事情，或者可能它们
to be over your head, but then you're going to go sit with people at lunch. And you're going to say, can you explain this to me a little bit more, because it seems interesting, and I don't really get it. And you're going to have some some nice person's going to say, like, I'd be happy to, you explain to them, now your friends, now when you get on the boat later on, maybe you meet their friends. And that's a seminar in general, right? It doesn't even have to be programming language specific. That's how all seminars generally work, which is that everybody sees the same thing. Everybody talks about the same things.
超出了你的理解范围，但接着你会在午餐时和大家坐在一起。你会说：“你能再给我解释一下这个吗？因为它看起来挺有趣，但我没太懂。”然后会有一个好心人说：“我很乐意。”你向他们解释，现在你们成朋友了。接着等你稍后上船时，也许你还会认识他们的朋友。这就是一般意义上的研讨会，对吧？它甚至不需要局限于特定的编程语言。所有研讨会通常都是这样运作的：每个人看到的是相同的内容，每个人讨论的是相同的事情。
And then you all sort of bond over that and you learn, right? So when you go home, you go like, I found out about testing, I found out about asynchronous programming, whatever it is, and you want to take that back with you and kind of let that percolate, figure out where it's going to come out in your in your day to day job. Second one is programming language conference, like just regular conference, which is like multi track conference, RubyConf is an example of this, you have a lot of different you have like three or four two three or four talks going on at the same time you have to pick
然后你们围绕这些建立某种纽带并学习新知，对吧？所以当你回家时，你会觉得：“我了解到了测试，我了解到了异步编程，无论是什么，”你想把这些带回去，让它们在脑海中沉淀，琢磨它们将如何在你的日常工作中发挥作用。第二种是编程语言大会，就像普通会议一样，是多轨同进行的。RubyConf 就是一个例子，你有很多不同的……大概同时有三四场演讲在进行，你必须选择
what you're going to go to there's lunch there's a keynote talk there's that kind of thing it's it's definitely a little more overwhelming people have to figure out where do i what do i go to right and i would always people always ask me that at those conferences and i would say like just if you don't know what to go to, just walk into a room, just wander into one of those rooms and sit down in the back and be like, what are we talking about? Right. Those are some of the best experiences you're going to have is if you never knew what you
你要去听哪一场。有午餐，有主旨演讲，诸如此类。这确实有点让人应接不暇，人们不得不琢磨：我该去哪里？我该听什么？在那种会议上，人们总是问我这个问题，而我的建议是：如果你不知道该去哪场，就随便走进一个房间，溜达进其中一个房间，在后排坐下来，心里想：“我们在聊什么呢？”没错。你将获得的最佳体验之一，往往就是那些你本来根本不知道自己在寻找什么，直到你坐在房间后排，发现有人在讨论 Ruby 反射机制之类的东西时产生的体验。所以，这是第二种。第三种类似于贸易展。RailsConf 就有点符合这种类型，它更像是一个贸易展，真正有实际的展厅，有参展商，有向你展示有趣事物的人，有赞助商，当然也有演讲。贸易展通常也包含继续教育的内容。但那里有很多地方是
were looking for until you sat in the back of the room and you found out, found somebody talking about Ruby reflection or something like that. So that's not, that's number two. Number three is sort of trade show. RailsConf kind of fits into this, this one, which is more like a trade show, which is really where you have an actual exhibit floor, you have exhibitors, you have people who are going to show you interesting things, you have sponsors, you can solve talks as well. Trade shows always have like continuing education. But there are a lot of places where
人们在寻找工作。人们在展示自己的公司。人们在进行社交。这更像是一个贸易展，它们都有各自的价值。它们都会带来某种程度的压迫感，把那种不知所措的感觉又推高了一个量级。不过是的，基本上就是这三种。这就是那三种
people are looking for jobs. People are showing off their companies. People are networking. That is more of a trade show and they all have their place. They're all sort of on the level of overwhelming. Those are ratcheting up the overwhelmingness on that thing. But yeah, there's sort of those three. Those are the three kind of
融合。太酷了。这很有道理。是的，如果你们听众中有谁担心某个会议是否适合自己，我想说：如果你觉得它适合你，那它就是适合你的。当你到场时你会惊讶地发现，那里有 200 个和你有着共同兴趣、可以畅所欲言的人。所以，哪怕你性格内向、害羞，或者不太确定自己该聊些什么，通常大家来这里都是因为对相同的事物感兴趣。而且我发现，这通常是一个非常温馨友好的体验。是的，绝对如此。如果你平时是一个非常内向的人，你可能会感到惊讶。但如果你有一个让你充满热情的课题，当你被其他有着相同兴趣的人包围时，你会惊讶于自己变成一个外向的人的速度有多快。前几天我看到一个笑话，有人说当他们在做计算机科学作业遇到困难时，会在 Stack Overflow 上提问。
blends. So cool. That makes sense. Yeah. If any of your listeners are worried about whether the conference is right for them, like, I would say if you think it's for you, it is for you. And you'll be surprised when you show up and there are 200 other people that have common interests that you can chat to about. So even if you're introverted, or you're shy, or you're not really sure, like what you're going to talk about, generally, folks are going to turn up because they're interested in the same things as you. And it's usually a very welcoming experience I found. Yeah, definitely. You'd be surprised to if you have, you might be sitting at home very introverted. But if you have a topic that's really passionate to you, you'd be amazed at how quickly you will become an extrovert when you're surrounded by other people who have the same interests. I saw this joke the other day where someone said when they have trouble with their CS homework, they ask a question on Stack Overflow.
然后他们会用第二个账号，也就是一个马甲账号给出错误的答案。这就是他们为了获得上百个正确答案需要做的事情。所以你知道的，有很多事情当你深入细节时，就会发现里面存在着不同的意见，并没有绝对唯一的正确答案。所以你会带着自己经过深思熟虑、投入了大量时间和精力的观点来到这里，然后你会遇到一个持有完全不同观点的人。你们俩会展开一场非常引人入胜的讨论。讨论结束后，你们可能会达成一个比刚开始时更加平衡的状态。所以，是的，这是我发现的一点。我挺内向的，曾经参加过一堆机器学习会议，但我发现当身处会议现场时，就会变成：“哦，是的，我真的很想解释这个东西，这是我的看法。”然后突然之间，所有这些话就滔滔不绝地涌出来了。我想说一件事，那就是我想强调一个大家可能叫法不同、但我们称之为“走廊闲聊”的东西。这是指你在会场里但不在会议厅听讲座时发生的事情。所以它不是在午餐时间之类的，对吧？因为在 Ruby 会议上，至少“走廊闲聊”和你在那里参加的任何其他时间一样有价值。我和迈克，我想，
And then they have a second account, a dummy account where they give the wrong answer. And then that's what they need to do to get like hundreds of right answers. So, you know, there's so many things where when you dive into the details, there's, you know, it comes from, there's sort of differing opinions and not really any right answer. And so you're going to come with your opinion that you've calcified, you've spent a lot of time and energy on, you're going to find someone with a totally different opinion. And the two of you are going to have a really engaging discussion. And at the end of it, you probably get to a place of even better balance than when you started. So yeah, that was
我想我们第一次见面是在奥兰多的宴会厅外面。基本上，那是 2006 年的 RubyConf 吧。那是在奥兰多。那是一家我们基本上离不开的酒店。它位于奥兰多一个不知名的地方。我们都被隔离在这家酒店里，但它是一家不错的酒店。我们所有人都觉得“走廊闲聊”太棒了，因为那里有那种 U 型沙发，最终会有 12 个人坐在其中一个 U 型沙发上，
one thing I found. I was pretty introverted, I was going to a bunch of machine learning conferences, but I found when I was at the conference, then it was like, Oh, yeah, I really want to explain this thing. And here's my take on it. And all of a sudden, like all these words start coming out. I wanted to say one thing, which is that I want to highlight what effectively I don't know what other people call it, but we call it the hallway track, which is the thing that happens when you're not in the sessions, but is during the conference time. So it's not at lunch or whatever, right? Because at Ruby conferences, at least the hallway track is as just as valuable as any other time that you will be there. Mike and I, I think,
有的人坐在地上，有的人坐在沙发上处理各种事情。我想，我不知道当时你是在搞 Nokogiri 还是 Hpricot，然后，你知道的，我们会聊天。我记得当时我和你还有亚伦一起调试 Web-XML 问题。“你知道这东西怎么运作吗？”然后就会有人说：“哦，我以前处理过这个。”你们就这么一来一回地切磋，对吧？然后你就会发现
I think our first time meeting was in Orlando outside the ballroom. Basically, this is RubyConf 2006, I'm going to say. It was in Orlando. It was in a hotel where we couldn't leave, basically. It was in kind of nowheresville in Orlando. We're all sort of sequestered in this hotel, but it was a nice hotel. And we all, the hallway track was amazing because there was like these U-shaped couches where there'd ended up, there would end up being like 12 people sitting in a U-shape, one of these U-shapes,
原来别人也对这个感兴趣，诸如此类，对吧？埃文，我还想指出一件事，我不知道你手头有没有这些数据，但在我参加过的每一届 RailsConf 或 RubyConf 上，在最初的主旨演讲期间，你都会问：有多少人是第一次参加 RubyConf？
some on the floor, some on the couches working on things. I think, I don't know if you're working on Nocaguiri or H-Percat at that point in time, but, and then, you know, yeah, we would talk. Like, I remember debugging WebXML issues with you and Aaron at that point in time. Like, you know, does anybody know how this thing works? And someone would be like, oh, I've dealt with that before. And you kind of just do that dance, right? And then you find
通常有一半的人会举手，对吧？是的，所以总是有一半的人。不管听起来多么疯狂，总是有一半的人。我是站在舞台上问这个问题的，所以我的视角可能会有点偏差。但最有趣的是，居然有一半的人是新面孔。对于正在收听这个节目、心里犯嘀咕的听众——比如 Rails 是不是……还有人在学它吗？这到底是不是个东西？——我想说，它绝对还是个东西。
that, like, oh, I didn't realize that other people were also interested in this or whatever, right? Something else I want to call out, Evan, I mean, I don't know if you have these numbers handy, but at every RailsConf or RubyConf I've been to, during the initial keynote, you ask, for how many people is this your first RubyConf?
每年都有成千上万的人是第一次学习 Rails。人们在训练营里学习它，在各种不同地方、以小型或大型规模使用它。RailsConf 上有 50% 是新人，这个事实对我来说意义重大，因为它说明了社区一直在变化，它充满活力。它不是每年都由固定的 500 人来重复讨论去年谈过的内容。我们以前在为会议规划日程、决定有哪些演讲时也讨论过这个问题。我们总是在想：我们还要再办这个演讲吗？然后我
And like half the room raises their hand usually, right? Yeah, so it's always half the room. Crazy as that may be, it's always half the room. I mean, I'm up on stage when I ask this question, so my perspective is a little skewed. But it's the most interesting thing that it's half the room. And I think for the audience who are listening to this and thinking, like, you know, is Rails something that I, like, are there people still picking it up? Is it a thing? It's very much still a thing.
不得不提醒大家：这个会议里 50% 的人将是全新面孔。所以即使你每年都办完全相同的演讲，
And there are so many people who are just learning Rails for the first time every single year. It's learned in boot camps. It's done in all kinds of different places at small scale, at large scale. And the fact that it's 50% at RailsConf is so important to me because of what it says is that the community is always changing. It's always vibrant. It's not the same 500 people who show up every single year to talk about the same thing they did last year. You know, we talk about that when we would work on the programming for, you know, the scheduling for what talks we're going to have. We always think, should we have this talk again? And I
也依然会有 50% 的人从来没听过。是的，这太疯狂了。所以，你当时在协助支持一个项目，我想那是个 Ruby 项目，那是 Ruby Central 吗？还是说 Ruby Central 是以后的事？是的，Ruby Central 是在美国成立的一个实际上的非营利组织，负责维护它。它最初成立的宗旨其实是为了举办会议，举办 RubyConf。他们需要一个实体来承担举办会议的保险压力（如果你这么说的话）。事情就是这样开始的。在我开始帮忙维护 RubyForge 和 rubygems.org 之后，当时的 Ruby Central 董事问我愿不愿意加入
have to remind people, 50% of this conference will be brand new. So you can have the same talk every single year. And, and people would 50% of people would never have heard it before. Yeah, that's, that's wild. So, so you're, you're helping the support on this, I think it was a Ruby project. And, and was that was that Ruby Central? Or is Ruby Central something in the future? Yeah, so Ruby Central is an actual nonprofit set up in the United States that maintains. It was set up originally actually to run the conference, to run RubyConf. They needed an entity that could basically take the insurance load, if you will, of running a conference. And that was how it started. And then after I started helping out with RubyForge and rubyjumps.org, I was asked by the then directors of Ruby Central if I wanted to be
董事会，愿不愿意从那个时候开始协助 Ruby Central 的工作。我说：“是的，我愿意。”因为我想确保事情真的能做成。所以，是的，我作为董事会成员开始协助 rubygems.org 的工作，然后开始帮忙筹办会议。我们在 2012 年的 RailsConf 上差点把整个组织搞垮。那是比这个播客时间更长的故事。但我很乐意在将来的某个契机分享它。那真的很棒。它跟连续三天吃肉派有关。这真的很棒。这是一个很长的故事，播客节目时间有限，但我很高兴在未来的某个节点讲给大家听。这很精彩。
on the board if I wanted to help out with with Ruby Central at that point. And I was like, yeah, I do. Because I want to make sure that stuff actually happens. So I, yeah, I started helping out with on with rubygems.org as a board member, and then started helping out with the conferences. We almost tanked the whole thing at RailsConf 2012. That's a longer story than this podcast is available for. But I'm happy to tell it as some future junction. It's great. It has to deal with eating pot pies for three days. It's great. It's a longer story than this podcast is available for, but I'm happy to tell it at some future junction. It's great. It has to deal with eating pot pies for three days. It's great.
这是一个很棒的故事。不过，是的，我就是从那时候开始参与进来的。Ruby Central 就是这个实体。所以 Ruby Central 是存在的，有董事会。他们现在有员工了，当年可没有员工，这也是为什么我们差点把它搞砸的原因。但现在他们有员工了，这也是为什么我们差点把它搞砸的原因。不过现在有了员工，它基本上负责维护
It's a great story. But, yeah, so I started getting involved then. And Ruby Central is the entity. So Ruby Central exists. There's directors. They have staff now. They didn't have staff back then, which is why we almost tanked it. But there's staff. which is why we almost tanked it. But their staff and it basically maintains
和组织 RubyConf 和 RailsConf，作为一个实体，它的全部存在意义就是改进 Ruby 语言及其社区。所以它就是为 rubygems.org 支付费用的实体。它支付所有的账单，管理所有与之相关的事情。所以它某种程度上是许多社区资源的拥有者。
and organizes the RubyConf and RailsConf is an entity that can just basically, all it exists to do is improve the Ruby language and their community. And so it is the entity that pays for rubygems.org. It pays all those bills. It manages all of the things related to that. So it sort of is the owner of a lot of community resource.
所以，是的。我今年去了 SciPyCon，这大概是我去过的最接近语言会议的活动了。但它是一个实体，我完全想不起运营它的那个实体叫什么名字了。不过我有机会和一些董事交谈，那感觉太疯狂了，简直是
So yeah, okay. So there's, I went to SciPyCon this year, which is, I guess, the closest thing I've been to a language conference. But it was an entity, and I'm totally drawing a blank on the entity that runs it. But I had a chance to talk to some of the directors and it was wild was wild i mean basically
疯狂。我的意思是，基本上，同一个实体也确保了 NumPy、SciPy、Dask 所有这些核心语言都有一个健康的生态系统。很多人把一些事情视为理所当然，比如如果在 Ruby 中遇到了类似内部编译器错误或内部解释器错误的东西，你在 GitHub 上提了一个 Issue，必须有人去处理它。这就造成了很大程度的“公地悲剧”，每个人都在索取，但真正能以高度组织化、专注的方式做出贡献的人却寥寥无几。关于 Ruby Central，我还想说一件事，因为我觉得多年来这一直是个误解。没关系，因为我们以前没有纠正它。Ruby Central 其实不怎么赚钱。它是个非营利组织。它的存在基本上就是为了把资金回馈给社区。所以当我们举办会议时，那真的只是为了支付
they that same entity also you know make sure that numpy scipy dask all these core languages have sort of a healthy ecosystem you know one thing a lot of people take for granted is you know if you file if you get you know an equivalent of of internal compiler error or internal interpreter error at Ruby, and you file an issue on GitHub, someone has to be there to catch that. And so that's a huge amount of a tragedy of the commons where everyone is kind of taking, but there isn't really somebody who can contribute and contribute in a really organized, focused way. Yeah. One thing I wanted to say about Ruby Central as well, because I think that this has been a misunderstanding over the years. It's fine because we didn't correct it. Ruby Central doesn't really make money. It's a nonprofit. It exists basically to just put money back into the community. So when we run a conference, it's really just to pay the bills
rubygems.org 的账单。所以我们总是对大家说：“我怎么能为 rubygems.org 做贡献呢？”我的回答是：“去参加其中一个会议，买张票。”在 2012 年之前，RailsConf 其实是由图书出版商 O'Reilly 运营的。所以那是由 O'Reilly 作为一个营利性实体来运营的。对吧？因为那是他们的业务所在。他们举办会议的目的就是为了营利。Ruby Central 接管了它。我们继续运营它。但我们当时想：“嘿，现在我们可以告诉你这笔钱去哪儿了。它是为了你们的利益。”我们当时想：“嘿，现在我们可以告诉你们这笔钱去哪儿了。它是为了你们的利益。我们收取资金，但基本上又以这些社区资源的形式
for rubygems.org. So we always tell people, how can I contribute to rubygems.org? I say, go to one of the conferences, buy a ticket. Prior to 2012, RailsConf was actually run by O'Reilly, the book publisher. And so and that was run kind of O'Reilly ran it as a for profit entity. Right. Because that was what they were in. That's why they run conferences is for profit. Ruby Central took it over. We continue to run it. But we were like, hey, now we can tell you where this money goes. It goes it's for you. We we were like, hey, now we can tell you where this money goes. It's for you. We basically take in the money, but we basically give it back to you in the form of these community
把它回馈给你们。”所以这背后并没有什么大型企业实体在收取代利去买私人飞机之类的事情。钱直接流进这里，然后基本上又被泵回到了社区中。是的，完全如此，这说得通。太酷了。是的，现在也许是个好时机，从宏观层面聊聊 Ruby。我第一次接触 Ruby 是通过一个叫 Jekyll 的软件，你可以用它搭建一个静态网站，这是我为一个 GitHub 项目需要的。让我对 Ruby 和 Rails 真正印象深刻的是，切换数据库以及诸如此类的事情是多么容易。所以我当时有一个使用 SQLite 数据库的开发版本，然后我还有一个生产版本，使用的是某种托管的，我想是托管的 MySQL 数据库。而所有这些
resources. So there's not some big corporate entity where they're just taking in profits to buy jets or something like that. It literally just goes in there to basically be pumped back out into the community yeah totally that makes sense so cool yeah this would be a good time maybe to talk about about ruby at a high level my my first interaction with ruby was through um this this uh software called jekyll where you could spin up a static website which I needed for a GitHub project and the thing that I was really impressed with with with Ruby and Rails was how easy it was to switch databases and and things like that so I had I had a development version which was using a SQLite database and then I had a production version that was using some type of hosted, I think it was like a hosted MySQL database. And all of that
在过去，当我用 Python 编写数据网络服务时，我必须从头构建所有这些东西。我必须写代码说：“好吧，检查某些环境变量。如果是这个，就使用开发数据库。哦，你知道的，我没有这个，或者我没有 MySQL 库。所以我必须去把它们拉进来。”这需要大量的手动工作。而使用 Ruby on Rails，你基本上可以免费获得所有这些。这就是我真正注意到的地方。所以，是的，也许凭借你的专业知识，你认为是什么让 Ruby on Rails 与众不同，
back in the, when I was writing data, web services in Python, I would have to build all of that from scratch. I'd have to say, okay, check some environment variable. If it's this, then use the development database. And oh, you know, I don't have the, or I don't have the MySQL library. So I have to go pull that in. It was a lot of manual effort. With Ruby on Rails, you kind of get all of that for free. That was the thing that I really noticed. So yeah, maybe, you know, with your kind of expertise, you know, what kind of separates Ruby on Rails from from um you know what kind of makes it distinct so i like to think about rails as being like really well vertically integrated pieces of
是什么让它独一无二呢？我喜欢把 Rails 视为高度垂直整合的软件，对吧？你可以从头开始构建一个网站，比如“哦，我自己挑选一个精雕细琢的数据库适配器，然后我想办法渲染视图，然后我想办法渲染视图。”而 Rails 过去和现在一直在做的事情，就是提出非常强烈的观点。这是你与数据库交互的方式。这是你渲染视图的方式。这是你编写控制器的方式。这是你编写所有模型的方式。这是你对所有模型进行单元测试的方式。作为一名开发者，这些约定真的让人感到非常解放。我喜欢不必去思考那些微小的细节，比如“当我做这件事时，我应该把这个文件放在哪个目录里？”你只需要说：“我需要一个新模型”，所有这些东西都会为你自动生成。我觉得多年来，其他网络
software right like you can come at building a website from like oh i'll pick my own like artisanal database adapter and then i'll figure out what how to render views then I'll figure out how to render views. And what Rails did and continues to do is put together pretty strong opinions. This is how you want to interact with the database. This is how you want to render your views. This is how you do your controller. This is how you do all of your models. And this is how you unit test all of your models. And those conventions are really liberating, I think, as a developer. I like not having to think about the small details, like, well, what directory do I stick this file in when I do the thing? Like you just say, I need a new model and all of these things like self inflate for you. And I feel like over the years, other web
框架也借鉴了许多这种强烈的约定和观点，比如 Django。如果你在 Django 中运行应用，我想 Django 多年来也从 Rails 那里借鉴了很多东西。所以至少对我而言，如果你追求的是“我想以尽可能快的速度让某些东西在互联网上运行起来，并且能够持续
frameworks have borrowed a lot of those same like strong conventions and opinions like Django. If you're if you're running an app in Django, I think Django has borrowed a lot of stuff from Rails over the years. So for me, at least, again, like if you're going for, I want to get something up and running on the internet as quickly as possible, that's going to set me up to continue
添加新功能，随着时间的推移保持这种超高的开发速度”，那么从第一天开箱之日起，Rails 真的就能作为软件开发者为你做好这一切。如果你想稍微出格一点，不按常规出牌，Rails 确实允许你随心所欲地进行配置。针对 Rails 的各个部分，也有许多非常有趣的插件和替代方案。但总的来说，我认为原汁原味的 Rails 是经营业务的绝佳方式。
to add new functionality and continue at this really high velocity over time. Like Rails really sets you up as a software developer to do all of that from day one out of the box. And if you want to color outside the lines a little bit, Rails does allow you to go ahead and configure it however you want. And there are a lot of really interesting plugins and alternatives for parts of Rails. But for the most part, I think Vanilla Rails is a great way to run a business.
这就是 Shopify 正在做的事情，我的团队的工作之一就是确保 Shopify 运行的是我们所能做到的最原汁原味的 Rails。如果我们确实需要一些特殊功能，我们会尝试将这些需求反哺到上游的开源社区中，让每个人都能受益。我想如果你看看其他公司，比如 GitHub 和 Airbnb，他们多年来也对 Rails 进行了上游贡献，使其成为一个更好的框架。现在我要为开源摇旗呐喊一下了，
This is what Shopify does. And part of what my team does is make sure that Shopify is running as vanilla a flavor of Rails as we possibly can. And if we need something special, we try to push that back upstream into open source so that everybody can benefit. And I think if you look at other companies like GitHub and Airbnb, they've made contributions back upstream to Rails over the years as well to make it a better framework. And now I'm going to like grind my open source axe for you a little bit and just be like,
这就是开源如此美妙的地方——这些公司在实际业务中认真地使用这些软件来完成真实的任务，他们都有动力去贡献，以保持飞轮转动，从而让软件变得更伟大，并吸引新的开发者加入社区。是的，我觉得 DHH（大卫·海涅迈尔·汉森，Rails 的创始人）曾多次说过类似的话，我用自己的话来转述一下，基本上就是：受到约束能帮助你变得更有创造力。
this is what makes open source so wonderful is that these companies that are using the software in anger to do something real are all motivated to contribute back to keep that flywheel going of making the software great and attracting new developers to the community. Yeah, I think DHH, David Hannon, the originator of Rails, he said it a couple of times, I'll paraphrase, which is basically that having constraints helps you be more creative.
这种哲学同样适用于你如何搭建你的技术栈，对吧？所以拥有所有这些观点也意味着会有更多的约束，比如“我必须用这个，我必须这样做，我必须使用这个组件”。现在，是的，这基本上意味着“如果我不想那样用，也许会觉得烦人”。但拥有这些约束并假设它们必定存在的另一面是，所有这些组件能够非常完美地协同工作。它们基本上让你能够说：“好吧，也许我不想花——或者大多数人不想花几个月的时间去弄清楚如何编写最好的 SQL 查询。”太好了。你不需要那样做。你可以使用 Active Record，
And that philosophy also is true in just how you set up your stack, right? So having all those opinions also means that there's more constraints like, oh, I have to use this, I have to do this, I have to use this one piece. Now, yes, that basically means that like, if I don't want to use it that way, maybe that's annoying. But the flip side of having those constraints and assuming that they're going to be there is that all of those things work really well in concert together. And they allow you to basically say like, okay, maybe I didn't want to spend or most people don't want to spend, you know, months trying to just figure out how to write the best SQL query. Great. You don't have to do that. You can use active record. And
作为技术栈的一部分，它虽然是一种约束，但也带来了难以置信的通用性。正如许多开发者所知，当你从一个项目转到另一个项目时——比如你在不同的公司之间跳槽，你在不同的公司之间跳槽，而它们都在编写 Web 应用——这几乎不影响你能够迅速上手新公司的应用，对吧？它可能是不同的语言。甚至即使它们都是 JavaScript，也可能大相径庭，完全是天壤之别，对吧？如果你在两家公司之间跳槽，而两家公司都说：“嘿，我们都在用 Rails 编写代码”，那么你在新公司的第一天可能就能保持很高的生产力。
that as a part of the stack as constraint, but it also adds an incredible amount of commonality. So that as a lot of developers will know, when you move from one project to another, so you move between companies, right? You move between companies and they're both writing web apps means almost nothing about the idea that you will be able to pick up the new company's app, right? It could be a different language. It could be, even if they're both JavaScript, they could be completely different, like off the wall different, right? If you move between two companies and both of them say, hey, we're both writing Rails, you'll probably be productive on your first day at the new company.
你可能会走进去说：“好的，你们是这样做，还是做了这个决定或那个决定？哦，你们选了这个？太酷了，明白了。”然后你就可以大展身手了，对吧？这种能力拥有巨大的威力，能让人们保持高效、满足所需，同时还能兼顾表达能力。我非常喜欢关于这种“有主见的框架”以及能够构建持久事物的讨论。我认为这是非常重要的一环。但它也是一个陷阱。我来简单讲一个“两个开发者的故事”。我在大学里有两个死党。
You'll probably go in and be like, okay, did you do this? Did you make this decision or this decision? Oh, you made this one? Cool. Got it. And then you're often off to the races, right? And that has such power in being able to have people be productive, fulfill what they need, and also be expressive at the same time. I love the talk about sort of the opinionated framework and being able to build something that lasts. I think it's such an important piece. And it's also a trap. I'll give kind of a quick tale of two developers. I have two buddies in college.
我们三个人一边吃披萨一边聊电子游戏。他们两个都想成为电子游戏开发者。而我只是坐在那里吃披萨，那不是我的菜。开发者，而我只是坐在那里吃披萨。但其中一个人说：“我想用 Unity，因为早在——我猜大概是 2005 年左右——Unity 就已经存在了，这是一个很好的入门方式。”另一个人则说：“不，我在 Unity 里做不了这个、这个和这个，我也做不了所有这些非常具体的事情。我觉得我们应该从头开始写一切，比如构建我们自己的游戏引擎，所有东西都自己造。”
The three of us were eating pizza and talking about video games. And the two of them both wanted to become video game developers. And I was just sitting there eating pizza. It's not my thing. developers, and I was just sitting there eating pizza. But one of them said, I want to use Unity, because even back in, I guess it was like 2005, Unity was around, and it was an easy way to get started. And the other one was saying, no, I can't do this and this and this in Unity, and I can't do all these really specific things. I think we should write everything from scratch, like build our own game engine, our own everything.
其实我不知道第二个家伙后来怎么样了。所以，我不知道，也许他真的自己做出了一个游戏引擎吧。我不知道。但第一个人确实开了一家独立游戏工作室，并且做得非常成功。所以我觉得我们作为富有创造力的人经常陷入的陷阱是，我们总是想要寻找最具创造力的媒介。最具创造力的媒介可以说是，我不知道，汇编语言之类的吧，对吧？在那里你可以绝对随心所欲地做任何事情。但问题是，实际上当你刚开始起步时，恰恰是你需要对你正在使用的特定范式
And I actually don't know what happened to that second guy. So I don't know. Maybe he made his own game engine. I don't know. But the first one actually started a game indie game studio and did really well. And so I think this trap that we fall into as creative people is we want to have the most creative medium. And the most creative medium is arguably like, I don't know, assembly or something, right? Where you can do absolutely everything. But the problem is that actually when you're getting started is when you need to be as
保持最少创造力的时候。所以，如果你以前从来没有建过网站，你应该专注于做一个不错的最终产品，并通过快速迭代在那里发挥创造力，而不是花大量时间去纠结：“哦，我该怎么做呢？如果我需要使用这个极其小众的图数据库怎么办？”所以，不要担心那些事情，先把东西搞定并运行起来。而这种带有主见的方案——无论你是在谈论 Next 还是 Rails——都会给你戴上非常精致的象牙手铐。一开始，你会说：“哦，我遇到了所有这些奇怪的错误，而且，哦，它不让我
least creative as possible with the particular paradigm you're working on. So if you've never built a website before, you should focus on having a nice end product and being able to be creative there by iterating quickly and not spend a lot of time saying, oh, how am I going to, you know, like, what if I need to use this really esoteric graph database, right? So don't worry about that stuff, just get the thing up and running. And the opinionated thing, whether you're talking about Next, or whether you're talking about Rails, it's going to put really polished ivory handcuffs on you. And in the beginning, you're going to say, oh, I'm getting all these weird errors. And, you know, oh, it's not letting me, you know,
把所有东西都放在同一个文件夹里，把所有源代码都放在同一个文件夹里，”因为至少对于 Next 来说，你知道的，文件夹、目录结构决定了 API。所以你会遇到各种障碍。但一旦你弄清楚了如何让你的东西适应那个范式，突然之间，你就会获得所有这些原本在你意识清醒范围之外的好处。所以突然之间你意识到：“哦，现在我明白了，如果我想添加一个组件，我可以在不破坏其他一切的情况下做到这一点。”所以，是的，我觉得这也是我个人经常陷入的一个陷阱，我会想：“哦，这个软件不允许我很方便地做 X，所以我要自己写一个。”结果不出所料，你自己写的东西永远也完不成。
put everything in the same folder, all the source code in the same folder, because at least for next, you know, the folder, the directory structure determines the API. So you find all these road blocks. But then once you've figured out how to make your thing fit in that paradigm, all of a sudden, you get all of these benefits that you are, that were outside of your, your conscious coherence. So all of a sudden you realize, Oh, now I see how, you know, if I wanted to add a piece, I can do that without, without breaking everything else. Right. So yeah, I think this is a trap I've personally have fallen into a lot as well, where I say, Oh, this, this piece of software doesn't easily let me do X. So I'm going to write my own thing. And then sure enough, your own thing never actually gets done.
我正想说，我经历过很多次这种情况。我喜欢将编程具体看作是一种艺术手艺，对吧？就像水管工一样，你可以拿起编程开始做。你可以从其他人那里学习。你可以读一本书。你可以向别人请教。你可以当学徒。你可以做所有这些事情，然后成为世界上最好的程序员。这个定义让它成为了一门手艺。但水彩画也是如此。水彩画也是一门手艺。你只要坐下来开始画水彩。你读本书，看别人是怎么画的，然后你就可以开始了，对吧？编程介于水管工和水彩画之间，对吧？关于水彩画最有趣的事情之一就是，当你决定这么做时，它是如此具有局限性。你会想：“天哪，我只能调出这样的颜色。我只有这些颜料。它只能用这种纸，对吧？”但想想看，仅仅通过画水彩，全世界涌现出了多少艺术创造力，对吧？
I was just going to say, I have been through this many times. And the way that I like to think of programming specifically is it's an artistic tradecraft, right? Like you can just like plumbing, you can pick up programming. You can start doing it. You can learn from other people. You can read a book. You can just ask somebody. You can be an apprentice. You can do all those things and you can be the best programmer in the world. That definition makes it a tradecraft. But so is watercolor painting. Watercolor painting is also a tradecraft. You just sit down and you start watercolor painting. You read a book, you look at it, how somebody did it. You just start doing it, right? Programming is somewhere between plumbing and watercolor, right? And one of the most interesting things about, say, watercolor is that when you decide to do that, it is so constricting. You're like, oh my gosh, I can only make colors like this. I've only got these kinds
这种约束在其他方面激发了创造力，可能比单纯的“哦，我需要表达自我，所以我需要花两年时间自己造纸”要有趣得多。太棒了，也许你能取得伟大的成就。但更有可能的是，如果你坐下来花两年时间学习如何在普通的纸上画水彩，你所能表达的自我可能要比你说“我需要世界上最好的纸”来得更好。谢谢你这么说，埃文。我百分之百同意。有一篇非常精彩的文章，是丹·麦金利（Dan McKinley）在 2015 年写的一篇博客文章。如果你们大家——如果听众们去谷歌搜索“选择无聊的技术”（choose boring technology），
of paints. It only works on this kind of paper, right? But think of the artistic creativity that's come out of just doing watercolors, right? The world over, right? That constraint breeds creativity in other ways that are potentially much more interesting than just being like, oh, well, I need to express myself. And so I need to spend two years making my own paper. Great. Maybe you will achieve something great. But more likely, if you sat down and just learned how to watercolor on normal paint for two years, you'd be able to express yourself potentially better than saying, I need the best paper in the world. Thank you for saying that, Evan. I agree 100%. There's a wonderful article, a blog post from 2015 by Dan McKinley, who if you all just, if you're listeners, Google for choose boring technology,
就能找到这篇文章。他在文章中引入了一个非常有趣的概念：创新代币。如果你在构建某个东西，你应该说：“好吧，我手头有两个代币，可以把它们用在某些创新技术上，而我做的其他所有事情都必须是无聊的。”这就迫使你在哪里承担风险、把时间花在重写游戏引擎、自己磨水彩颜料或是自己造纸上做出选择？思考一下你追求的核心竞争力是什么？如果你想创办一家新游戏公司，其基础是更快的帧率，也许你确实想去构建自己的游戏引擎。是的。但如果你想创办一家以超级好玩的内容为核心的游戏公司，那么游戏引擎可能就会分散你的精力，
you will find this essay. And he introduces this really interesting concept of innovation tokens. Like if you're building a thing, you should say, okay, I have two tokens that I can use for some innovative technology and everything else I do has to be boring. And this forces you to make the choice about where do you want to take that risk? Where do you want to spend that time to rewrite a gaming engine or go grind your own watercolor paint color or make your own paper? And think about what is the core competency that you're going for? Like if you want to start a new gaming company that's predicated on faster frame rates, maybe you want to go build your own gaming engine. Yes. But if you want to build a gaming company built around like super fun stuff, maybe the gaming engine is a distraction
你应该使用现成的标准产品，把时间和精力投入到让游戏变得超级好玩上。我对 Web 开发也是这么看的。我可以从头编写自己的 Socket 处理程序，或者我可以直接使用现成的负载均衡器，而且，你知道的，一路上你可以做出无数的权衡，人们应该可以自由地做出这些权衡，但我的看法是：在你实际上并不需要竞争优势的地方，选择无聊的技术。是的，这很有道理。这其实是一个悖论，对吧？因为如果你能让某种东西完美契合，我想到了水彩画的例子。你会看到这样的例子：人们采用了一种在水彩或任何其他媒介中都极其难以表达的风格，但他们却成功将其实现了。
and you should use something that's standard off the shelf and put your time and effort into making that game super fun. And I think about web development the same way. Like I could write my own like socket handler from scratch, or I could just use like a load balancer off the shelf and just, you know, there's, there's a ton of trade-offs that you can make along the way and people should feel free to make those trade-offs, but like choose boring where you don't actually need a competitive advantage is how I would think about it. Yeah, that makes sense. It's actually a paradox, right? Because if you can make something fit, I'm thinking about the watercolor example. You see examples where people take a style that's very difficult to express in watercolor or in any other medium and they make it happen
你应该使用标准的、现成的东西，把你的时间和精力花在让游戏变得超级好玩上。我认为网页开发也是一样的。就像我可以从头编写自己的套接字处理程序一样，或者我可以直接使用现成的负载均衡器，你知道的，在这个过程中你可以做出大量的权衡，人们应该可以自由地做出这些权衡，但如果你实际上不需要竞争优势，那就选择无趣的技术栈，我是这么看的。是的，这说得通。这其实是一个悖论，对吧？因为如果你能让某些东西契合，我在想水彩画的例子。你会看到这样的例子：人们采用一种用或者任何其他媒介都很难表达的风格，然后他们把它实现了。
and people really appreciate that. It's sort of like when you see these pixel art, your gigantic landscapes and pixel art and all of that. And so, and so, um, uh, you know, that could be sort of part of the challenge instead of saying, well, I'm going to write everything from scratch. And, uh, that way I could be as creative as possible, say, I'm going to make this work in this framework. And that actually is going to force me to be as creative as possible. You know, ostensibly, Ruby is a language, Rails is a set of frameworks, but, you know, like, where is sort of the gap there? What other things is Ruby used for?
and people really appreciate that. It's sort of like when you see these pixel art, your gigantic landscapes and pixel art and all of that. And so, and so, um, uh, you know, that could be sort of part of the challenge instead of saying, well, I'm going to write everything from scratch. And, uh, that way I could be as creativity as possible, say, I'm going to make this work in this framework. And that actually is going to force me to be as creative as possible. You know, ostensibly, Ruby is a language, Rails is a set of frameworks, but, you know, like, where is sort of the gap there? What other things is Ruby used for?
Other than Rails, like, what kind of captures a lot of the Ruby market share? And how do we sort of differentiate these two things for people? Yeah, I think if we were having this conversation six years ago, I would probably say DevOps was also in that group, right? So famously, Puppet and Chef are both written in Ruby. Oh, I didn't know that.
Yeah. So if you go to write Chef cookbooks, you write Ruby. If you go write Puppet thingamabobs, I can't remember what the noun is for puppet. Plans, I don't know. Yeah, you go to write puppet Pinocchios, then you actually write them in Puppets specific DSL, but that DSL is actually parsed in Ruby. So if you wanted to extend Puppet, do different things, you actually write Ruby on the backend. So that was big. Those things were both that were born out of this time, this interesting time in the programming community. The zeitgeist of Ruby circa 2010, 2009, around that time where people were like,
hey, let's write everything in Ruby. And DevOps was coming up and cloud was getting big and we hadn't really hit containers yet. And that was really the era of those tools. Those tools still exist. People still use them every day. I would say that they're probably on the down slope a little bit right now because cloud and containerization
have given people different ways of solving the problems that those same things solved. And so you don't see them as used as much anymore. I think Rails is still the 800-pound gorilla in the Ruby community. I think there are other people. You can write, I mean, it's Turing complete.
You can certainly write other programs in it. People write all kinds of other services, non-Rails, web services, internal services, all kinds of stuff like that in Ruby as well. But I think that service-based applications, be it web or otherwise, are probably the lion's share of what we see in Ruby today. What do you think, Mike? Yeah, I would agree. I think there's a healthy number of people who are pushing Ruby towards being a better platform for big data analysis. The big Ruby conference in Japan happened last week, Ruby Kaigi. There's been a series of talks over the last few years
about how to integrate Ruby with Apache Arrow and how to get low latency data access and how to do OLTP and OLAP. And I think that's really, really interesting because I think Python has been the dominating language for a lot of that. And there's no reason Ruby can't be equivalent, except that we don't have a lot of the same libraries that the Python community has invested in over the years. And so I do see some hints there of like, well, what are the interesting things that Ruby hasn't traditionally been used for, like big data and pushing in that direction,
which I really like. Yeah, that makes sense. There was a big effort, Swift Torch, it was this effort to do tensor processing in Swift. And that, I think it was Google actually was pushing that, even though Swift is an Apple thing. I think Google is really pushing this like Swift TensorFlow and Swift Torch. I don't know what happened to that, but I think there is a space for other languages to be in that domain. I think there's a lot of times you need to do tensor processing, you know, no matter where you are. So imagine if you are trying to do some analytics on, you know, within your web service. You're seeing a lot of this now where, you know, as the third party cookies and other things are getting blocked, you know, people have to push the analytics to the server side. So it used to be just a bit of background used to be, you know, anytime you would, well, depending on how they set up the website,
but maybe every time you click on something, you know, it would send a little packet of information over to Google that would then make its way into that company. So for example, you're running a website for your pizza place, and you want to know how many times are people clicking on your menu bar. So you would set up Google Analytics. Every time someone clicks on your menu bar, it fires a little packet of energy to Google. Google accumulates all these and sends it to you. So now if someone's using Brave or using, I think the new Safari has this, those are all blocked. So, you know, if I'm talking to, you know, PizzaHut.com, I can't actually, my browser will actually block packets going to Google if I'm supposed to be talking to Pizza Hut.
And so what that does is it forces all the analytics to have to go to the back end. So that, to use this example, every time I click on the menu, I send a little packet over to Pizza Hut, and then Pizza Hut can then pass it on to Google, or they could even do the analytics themselves. And so that's where I think we'll start to see more of a need to do these kind of tensor operations and calculating distributions and these other things in Ruby, in Node, in all of these different languages. So rewind your mind back to 2004. What was the piece of software that
started with web that analyzed your Apache logs and basically gave you these really great graphs of like, who is accessing your website from where and all that kind of stuff. Basically, it's fascinating that we're returning to that era of things. I know exactly what you're talking about. I can see the graph in my head. Yeah. Yeah. I ran that for a while for my research lab. Yeah. Anyway, on the topic of like, you know, what does Ruby use for? I think that one of the things that you see over and over again in the apps, the kinds of programs that Ruby is really good at, is they're largely applications
that are highly dynamic. And by that, I mean that they go through heavy development cycles constantly, right? That is where Ruby and Ruby is supremely, supremely good at and Rails makes it even better, right? In that same way that like, for instance, if you were like, I need to write an app, and I'm never going to change it and needs to be as fast as possible. Ruby ends up being kind of a weird use case, because it's like, it's not really optimized for that kind of use usage. Right. And then on the flip side, right. If you write, if you want to write a web, little web thing, and it's going to go inside to say, uh, a wifi router, right. You might write that and see, because I got to just, I got to write it one time and I needs to run in like the tiniest memory footprint possible because it's running on a little teeny MIPS chip, right? But I'm never going to change it. So it might be awful to write the
first time, but I'm never going to go back to it. And so I don't really care, right? And so that spectrum of dynamism is really where you find Ruby at that far end where you're like, hey, look, every day, like Mike can speak to this better than I can. But one of the amazing things about Ruby and Rails is the number of people that you can have that are simultaneously working on the same code base and not stepping on each other's toes. That probably is the biggest feature of Ruby. Rails enables that with convention, but it is astounding. I mean, Mike, maybe you can speak to this. What is the largest team that works on a single app inside Shopify, you think? I mean, the big monolith that we have on any given week probably has 800
contributors. To one app, to one GitHub repo. To one GitHub repository, one Rails application. Yeah. I mean, just hundreds of PRs a day get shipped to production. How do you A-B test that? We test to production. No, I'm joking. So I think we really embrace the fast rollback paradigm, right? It's like we're going to be fast to ship it.
And we have great observability into what's going on in production. And if something's wrong, we can roll back instantly. And so that makes the risk of failure really, really low, which means that we generally will roll forward. If something is wrong at production, we'll roll forward as often as we can. When we need to, we can back out. And we do have A-B testing frameworks, don't get me wrong. But for the most part, I think we're all developing on main. We're pushing from main. And it's managed to scale. We just have A-B testing frameworks, don't get me wrong. But for the most part, I think we're all developing on main. We're pushing from main and it's managed to scale. We just have great tooling.
Wow, that's awesome. Yeah, that is such a, like, if I were to, someone said, you got to spend money to buy a banner that basically says like why someone should use Rails. It would probably be that. It would probably be like, hey, do you want to work on the same app with 800 of your friends? This is probably what like, Hey, do you want to work on the same app with 800 of your
friends? This is probably what you should use, right? Because I think if you were to try to go around and evaluate that condition amongst different languages and different places, you find all of these places where stuff falls down. Oh, well, everybody has to write to this and then that, right? The fact that that is, i don't know that they necessarily meant that to happen but the the conditions allowed for it to to be the case that makes sense what about uh scalability so so i mean clearly rail scales because look at where it's being used but you know how does that actually work so is rails um is is Rails like sitting on a thread pool or do you spin up a bunch of copies of it on a single server? Like what's the scalability part like?
Yeah, that's all me. So one of the things I did during Rubinius was I wrote a web server for Ruby. And it was specifically to make advantage of the characteristics of Rubinius. One of the characteristics of Rubinius was it had native threads available to it that could run concurrently. And so I was like, okay, I need a web server that can really take advantage of that situation. And I coded it in a certain way that it could take advantage of it, but it used the normal API. That web server was called Puma. And that web server has sort of become the dominant Ruby web server today. And it uses techniques that come from WebRick, which is
the original web server framework that actually built into Ruby itself. Techniques that come from Unicorn, which was a web server that was created in the 2007, 8-esque era that still powers GitHub and kind of combines a bunch of different elements in order to give people all the right knobs that they need to do things. So what generally people do is a combination of three things. They utilize a thread pool in a single process. So it's like, okay, great. I know that my app's going to be blocked on talking to the database a good amount of the time anyway. I'm going to use a thread pool and I'm just going to basically handle requests through a thread pool. Ruby's concurrency model is the similar to Python's and that it's, you're not going to have multiple native threads running concurrently.
They're going to be blocked in IO. They're going to switch control, but in a web app, very rarely matters because a lot of times you're waiting on backend for processing and that kind of thing. Yeah. Let me just like dive into that a little bit for folks at home. So it sounds like there's like a global interpreter lock in Ruby, similar to Python. Yeah. So the way these languages work, imagine you have a, so using like Python or Ruby, you have automatic garbage collection. You have all these features that are built into the language. And so it becomes really difficult if you have to handle concurrency there.
So imagine you have a Python instruction that's adding a reference to an object. And you have another Python instruction that is removing that reference. If they can both run at the same time, you have race conditions. And that's just one of many examples where it becomes extremely difficult. So what most languages do is they say, you can only execute one instruction in a process at a time. Now, what happens is your instruction might say, I'm waiting for a packet to arrive over the network.
And so you want all the other threads to be blocked just because this one instruction hasn't finished yet. So certain instructions can what's called release the lock, where they can say, I'm waiting on this network packet. Until it arrives, someone else can execute instructions because I know that I'm waiting for this packet, and I'm not going to change the reference count on the objects, for example. And so then when this network packet arrives, then that same instruction says, oh, now I'm awake
again. Now I'm going to get the lock. I'm going to do some work with this packet. And then when I'm done with that instruction, now it'll go back to the, to the machine to, to decide what instruction to run next. And so, you know, if you, and so in this way, like, even though you can only execute any one instruction at a time, you can still get a ton of concurrency as long as most of the time you're releasing this lock because you're talking to a database or waiting for a network packet or something like that. Yep, exactly right. So you have these three knobs, right? You have threads, which you can tune up and down basically how many requests you want an individual process to handle at the same time, basically locking and unlocking. And you have workers, which is effectively how many
processes you want, right? It's going to use Unix forking in order to basically say like, I need more of these things. And then all of those things aren't going to share memory so they can run truly concurrent, they can share the same socket so they can handle different things uses the same technique that the Apache web server came up with back in time memoriam, right of like, I'm gonna just have multiple processes listing on the same socket on the Unix side, right? And so basically, what I tell people is, you just sit there, and you just tune those knobs, right? You say like, okay, great, like, I need to, I want to hit a certain request per second, okay, I'm going to turn up the threads, you know, at a certain
processes you want, right? It's going to use Unix forking in order to basically say like, I need more of these things. And then all of those things aren't going to share memory so they can run truly concurrent, they can share the same socket so they can handle different things uses the same technique that the Apache web server came up with back in time memoriam, right? Of like, I'm gonna just have multiple processes listing on the same socket on the Unix side, right? And so basically, what I tell people is, you just sit there, and you just tune those knobs, right? You say like, okay, great, like, I need to, I want to hit a certain request per second, okay, I'm going to turn up the threads, you know, at a certain
point, turning up the threads will actually hurt your request per second, because you'll basically be handling, you'll be accepting more requests than you can actually handle in your throughput for how quickly you can get around to threads. So then you, oh yeah, that was too many. Let me turn it back down. Let me turn the workers up a little bit. Because every time you turn workers up, you increase your memory footprint, right? So you just turn those two knobs and eventually you find a sweet spot that's for your app.
And once you find that sweet spot, then you say like, okay, great. Wherever you're running, your container engine, your VMs, whatever you say, like, okay, great. That's our multiplier, or that's our fixed number of requests per second. Now I want to multiply it. And then you just, you just apply a multiplier of instances. You say like, okay, we got 1000, we need to hit 1000 requests per second. And one of our tuning can hit a hundred requests per second, let's just say. So now I need 10 of those things. Great. Let me just fire up 10 of them and you're done.
You go to lunch. Yeah. Is having multiple processes, how does that compare to running multiple pods in Kubernetes? Right. So you can, in Kubernetes, you can say, you know, I want four pods and you might get all four pods on the same machine. Is that like, what efficiency loss is there between that and just running four processes? So there is an efficiency. It's not as significant, but the reason that it exists to do it natively is to take advantage of a functionality that's built into Unix operating systems, which is what people mostly deploy on,
called copy on write memory. So what you will do is you'll load your app in, right? Let's just say you have a fairly big app, and it's going to load the whole app into memory. It's going to parse it, load all the objects, do all the initialization, and let's say that your footprint is 150 megabytes, right? So you loaded all that stuff in, it was 150 megabytes. So you load it into one process. And then what you do is you fork that process. So basically, you make a clone of it. And what happens when you make a clone of it is that clone has its own memory, it never gonna, it's never gonna touch the parent. But what Unix systems do is they actually don't they delay performing the copy until the latest possible time.
So if I can still read memory and it reads from the parent, and if I write to it, it will copy it. That's the copy on write. And so what happens is that if you do that, what you get is memory efficiency by using that sort of worker model where you can fork because you will get this shared sort of memory pool that comes from the original start and that the memory that's used by the individual worker processes will just be the memory that's required to process each individual request. So you can achieve some memory savings. And again, it kind of depends on the size of your
application, what you're doing a little bit with it, that kind of thing. It might also be worth mentioning here, I'll give a shout out to my colleague, Jean Boussier, who has recently proposed in Ruby to have an API call that says, now we are ready to do that copy and write, to fork a new process to do the copy and write thing so that the Ruby VM is now being optimized for the web context that is running in for Rails, which is really interesting. It's like Rails requirements making its way into Ruby. But the idea is that Ruby does as much upfront as it possibly can. And then you signal, okay, now I'm ready to fork so that as much memory as possible won't be written to afterwards like that that mechanism that evan just explained we're going to defer more and more and more of that writing or try to do it up front if we can yeah that makes sense um yeah i saw this uh this really compelling
um it was a blog or a tutorial where someone was using ZFS, which has copy on write as well. And so what they were able to do is basically take their, I think it was their family photos or something that was really large, like gigabytes and gigabytes, and basically copy it this you say oh there's a cron job that's doing you know uh cp directory directory and this directory is 20 gig and it's doing it every day oh my god this can't possibly be sustainable but but under the hood zfs is is is smart enough to say oh just keep references here and if someone changes a file now actually just transparently make the copy um and so yeah fork does something similar for memory i've gotten burned by fork in the past i don't remember exactly what it was but there was something with uh it had to do with cuda and the gpu um so when you start getting into gpu memory and some of these things you have to to be careful. I know Torch now switched to using Spawn
instead of Fork, which does make like a complete copy, a deep copy of everything. But yeah, if you're not doing crazy GPU stuff, Fork is more than adequate. Yeah, I think that there are so many foot guns around Fork specifically, because one of the other... I love that word, foot gun. Yeah, one of the other specific ones yeah yeah what what are the other specific ones and this is probably what you hit is that the semantics of fork are uh let's see it's 2022 now so the semantics of fork are 50 years old now or so and so there's all these efficiencies that were built into fork that aren't useful anymore but we we still pay for by pay for in the quantity of foot guns that are available to you on a daily basis. And so like the resources, so for instance,
instead of Fork, which does make like a complete copy, a deep copy of everything. But yeah, if you're not doing crazy GPU stuff, Fork is more than adequate. Yeah, I think that there are so many foot guns around Fork specifically, because one of the other... I love that word, foot gun. Yeah, one of the other specific ones yeah yeah what what are the other specific ones and this is probably what you hit is that the semantics of fork are  let's see it's 2022 now so the semantics of fork are 50 years old now or so and so there's all these efficiencies that were built into fork that aren't useful anymore but we we still pay for by pay for in the quantity of foot guns that are available to you on a daily basis. And so like the resources, so for instance,
file descriptors are shared between two processes, right? So if you open a file and you fork that other thing still has access to the same file. Yeah's cool that's maybe useful it can be very useful it is so problematic if you don't know that it's happening in certain cases right there's two processes that are advancing the file just the file at the same time and trend and getting parts of it and all kinds of crazy stuff things like semaphores and all kinds of os related handles are copied. They're not copied. They're shared between those two. It's really just memory, for the most part, that is a copy.
Everything else ends up being this share. And I think Spawn lets you say, I want a whole fresh new coat of paint here. Don't share any. I don't want the same cup holders as the old one. I don't want the same gas pedal as the same. I want all new stuff. And so, yeah. Yeah. So this is a perfect time to just remind people, if you don't want to have to learn the hard way about fork versus spawn and spend days on it, like we have, use Ruby on Rails. Like, don't build your own web service, you know, that's just one rabbit hole
you'll end up having to go down. And actually, you know, if you're really interested in that level of detail, that's great. I mean, you can work on making any one of these frameworks a lot better. But chances are, you'll want to at least start by doing something high level and using something like Rails. Let's jump a little bit into, you know, what you all have kind of been up to and how folks can kind of contribute and be a part of this. So I think, you know, if someone is, you know, super enthusiastic about Rails, you know, it sounds like like Shopify and Ruby Central are both kind of places where they can go to and contribute and learn more about. Why don't you maybe talk about what are some of the opportunities out there for folks maybe who are just graduating college or maybe they're still in college?
Sure. Well, I think that the first thing I would say is there are indeed Ruby and Rails jobs out there. They're in demand and they pay well. So number one, if you're interested in doing Ruby, you can always reach out to Shopify or a number of other Ruby shops, which is great. There's my plug for Shopify hiring. What is the state with remote? And is it sort of US?
Is it global? Shopify is hiring globally right now. So we, post-pandemic, moved into a post-office world. We don't have offices anymore. Everyone is fully remote. That was a big step change for Shopify because Shopify had kind of built its identity
around in-person offices with great perks, right? Where people could go after work and go to 3D print something or play ping pong or have a great lunch with their colleagues. And the in-person experience is just not available anymore. But the flip side of that is that we can now hire amazing people anywhere they are in the world. And so teams generally find a few time zones that they are affiliated with,
right? So like maybe a team chooses to be mainly East Coast US, but also work a little bit earlier to handle European colleagues or vice versa. They're on the West Coast and maybe they shift a little bit later to have some PACRIM colleagues in Japan or Australia. And so it's a really, really flexible place to work. And if you're interested at all, please reach out. What about internships? Are there internship opportunities for people who are still students? Yes, absolutely. So we have internships, of course. And I think we also have a really great program called the Dev Degree Internship, which is for folks who are in college and need co-op opportunities. They can actually spend a few years alternating between
a semester at school and a semester working at Shopify on a real team. And I think the conversion rate of that program has been huge. A lot of really talented folks have stuck around and taken full-time jobs afterwards. And that's a great opportunity as well. It's called the Dev Degree Program. Cool. That makes sense. Just out of curiosity, Shopify, I believe it was in Canada. Is that right? Before the remote thing? It is a Canadian company at its heart. Yes. Everyone is super nice, just like all Canadians are. Shopify was founded and the main headquarters has always been in Ottawa. Got it. Ottawa is not exactly a gigantic metropolis.
It's kind of, I would call it like maybe a second tier city. It's not in New York or Chicago or in LA. But Shopify built this reputation as being the best tech employer in Ottawa. And that fueled a lot of its growth for about a decade. Wow, that is wild. So is it kind of like totally remote now? Is it since like the lease is disbanded and there isn't an office? So I think we still have some real estate in a few offices, but we use that for like team off sites.
Essentially, we use the verb burst for it because the teams come together and they like burst in happiness and productivity. But they're mainly used as like co-working sites where teams come together for three or four days to maybe finish a project, shape up style. And there's nobody going into that office every day for work anymore. That is wild. So the things you talked about, the 3D printing and the perks, all of that, what have you work to be missing. And so Shopify has done a bunch of things, I think, to try to address this. We do a lot of social events, so teams get together. My team has a show and tell or a social thing on a Tuesday afternoon. We do coffee on Friday afternoon.
We have a couple of other events that we do. And that at least gives us an opportunity to get together and just chat and be social, which is great. We try to get together as often as we can, like at least a few times a year. Most teams will get together in person at these like off sites. Shopify also has really great perks for at home. Like we, you know, I think new employees will get a budget to build out a home office so that they're comfortable at least if they can't have an office to commit to, they can be comfortable at home. And I think that it's a trade-off though, right? So folks who really... I find a lot of folks who
are right out of college, their social lives become the network of people that they know from work. I know I did this, right? I married my wife who I met at work at my first job, right? I think that it is, it's a choice that everybody has to make for themselves, whether they want to be in person now that we're kind of like, I don't want to say we're past the pandemic, because I don't think that's true. But a lot of places have their offices open again. And I think that's a choice everybody needs to make for themselves. But I've been super happy at Shopify. I really love it. Yeah, that makes sense. So when folks do get together in person, that's got to be a fascinating thing. I mean, I remember I recently went to a new job. I took a
new job about a year ago and were in person. But before that, there were people who I had brought on to the team maybe two years prior. And even two years later, I'd never met them in person. And so, you know, getting together, it's really interesting. You kind of have to say, well, you know, here's my sort of, here's the nonverbal side of me. You know, here's like the part of me, like outside of the rectangle of the Zoom call, right? And then also at the same time, maybe we could do something productive while we're here. Yeah, for my day job, I work for HashiCorp, which we haven't talked about here
because it's not really Ruby related, but we do the same thing. And I was just going to say, whenever we're also fully remote and have been for quite some time, one of the things I always have to tell people is, by the way, I'm 6'4", just so you know, because you can't tell at all. And so the first time people meet me, they're like, oh my God, I had no idea. I was like, I know it's because my head is well proportioned
with my shoulders. So there's no way you could tell on Zoom that I'm this tall. And we make this joke every single time. And yet every single time I meet people in person for the first time, they're like, you weren't kidding. And I was like, no, I was not. So I have the same thing where I have my, I think part of it too, is my camera. I don't use my laptop camera because just the way my desk is set up, I would be like heavily backlit. It would, it would look like I'm in a witness protection program or something. So I got a camera and it just happens to have a pretty wide lens. So my, my head and my body just looks small because there's so much other room. And then people meet me and I'm 6'2". And they're like, oh my God, you're so tall. Yeah, that's wild. shopify.com slash careers or slash jobs, we'll put the right link up in the show notes for folks. So if you're listening at home, go to the show notes. Almost any podcast app has a little notes
用我的肩膀。所以在Zoom上你绝对看不出我有这么高。我们每次都开这个玩笑。然而每次我第一次和大家线下见面时，他们都说，你没开玩笑吧。我说，不，我没开玩笑。所以我也遇到过这种情况，我有我的，我觉得部分原因也是我的摄像头。我不用笔记本电脑的摄像头，因为我书桌的摆放方式，会导致我严重逆光。那会，那会看起来就像我在参加证人保护计划什么的。所以我买了一个摄像头，它正好有一个相当广的镜头。所以我的，我的头和我的身体看起来很小，因为有太多其他的空间。然后人们见到我，我有6英尺2英寸。他们会说，哦天哪，你太高了。是的，太疯狂了。shopify.com slash careers 或者 slash jobs，我们会在节目简介里放上正确的链接供大家参考。所以如果你在家里收听，去看看节目简介。几乎任何播客应用都有一个小笔记
section. And so we'll put a link in there. You can just click straight in. Cool. I didn't mean to turn that into a whole employment pitch for Shopify, but I really do love working with Shopify. No, it's cool. I'm a big fan of following Shopify. There was a really interesting blog post that the CEO of Shopify made. I'll have to go back and find it. But it really struck me. It had to do with, so basically, you know, Shopify is sort of has this like content farms where they're creating all of this content, but then the content creators are not really connected to the ad system. The ad system is really the centralized YouTube thing. And so it's almost like, like there are kickbacks, but it's completely up to YouTube versus Shopify is like truly a marketplace that's like sort of building up, as you said, a lot of small businesses, which is really nice to see. Yeah, that's absolutely right.
部分。所以我们会在里面放一个链接。你可以直接点进去。酷。我不是故意要把这变成对Shopify的整体招聘推销，但我确实非常喜欢在Shopify工作。不，这挺酷的。我是Shopify的忠实粉丝。Shopify的CEO写过一篇非常有趣的博客文章。我得回头去找找。但它真的触动了我。它与……所以基本上，你知道，Shopify有点像有这种内容农场，他们在创作所有这些内容，但内容创作者并没有真正连接到广告系统。广告系统实际上是集中的YouTube东西。所以这几乎就像，就像有回扣，但完全取决于YouTube，而Shopify真正是一个像你所说的那样正在建立许多小企业的市场，这真的很高兴看到。是的，完全正确。
I think the store owners own their own brand. They have their own domain. Maybe the flip side of that would be Amazon, where if you have something to sell, people are still going to Amazon.com and searching. And then Amazon gets to show competitors up against your thing too. And for us, it really is about putting the merchant front and center, allowing them to build their brand, allowing them to build an audience or customers that come back over and over again. And they own that asset, right? It happens to run on Shopify's Rails app on our hardware, but they actually own that storefront themselves and all the information about their customers they own and not Shopify. Yeah, I happen to be looking for an e-bike for
我认为店主拥有他们自己的品牌。他们有自己的域名。也许另一面就是亚马逊，如果你有什么要卖的，人们仍然会去Amazon.com搜索。然后亚马逊也会把竞争对手的产品展示在你的产品旁边。对我们来说，这真的是把商家放在首位和中心，让他们建立自己的品牌，让他们建立能够一次又一次回访的受众或客户。他们拥有那个资产，对吧？它碰巧运行在Shopify的Rails应用和我们的硬件上，但他们实际上拥有他们自己的店面以及关于他们客户的所有信息，而不是Shopify。是的，我刚好在为
my wife and I was gone to Aventon.com. They sell e-bikes. And it actually is a Shopify site. And the reason why I started going directly to these companies was something kind of, you know, sometimes something small happens, but ends up kind of leaving a big impact. And for me, I was searching for, I typed in Duracell batteries, and I got Amazon Basics batteries as the first choice. And for some reason, that had a really big impact on me. I was thinking, wow, I'm probably missing out on actually the best product here. So yeah, I think it's an amazing platform. It's really cool stuff.
我妻子寻找一辆电动自行车，我去了Aventon.com。他们销售电动自行车。它实际上是一个Shopify网站。我开始直接去这些公司的原因有点……你知道，有时发生一些小事，但最终会留下很大的影响。对我来说，我在搜索，我输入了金霸王电池，结果作为首选出来的是Amazon Basics电池。出于某种原因，这对我产生了非常大的影响。我在想，哇，我可能错过了这里真正最好的产品。所以是的，我认为这是一个了不起的平台。这真的是很酷的东西。
If you're looking out there for internships, jobs, definitely a good place to go. And there's no physical limitation there. So you could be out in Idaho, you could be anywhere and you should definitely reach out. What about you, Evan? Like are there folks, you have hiring opportunities
如果你正在寻找实习、工作，这绝对是个好去处。而且那里没有任何地域限制。所以你可以远在爱达荷州，你可以身处任何地方，你绝对应该联系我们。你呢，Evan？比如有没有人，你现在有招聘机会吗
either at HashiCorp or through Ruby Central? Yeah, I mean, Ruby Central, I think is really small. I think that there's not a lot of positions. And I resigned as a director there a couple of months ago. So I don't have the latest either. But one of the things that I know that Ruby Central is doing right now is working with the Ruby Shield program with Shopify to take some of the, to basically to use the money, the funds that have been income available to hire people. So like one of the things that we're looking to do is hire people who are interested in Ruby
是在HashiCorp还是通过Ruby Central？是的，我的意思是，Ruby Central，我认为真的很小。我认为没有很多职位。而且我在几个月前辞去了那里的董事职务。所以我也没有最新的消息。但我知道Ruby Central现在正在做的事情之一是与Shopify的Ruby Shield程序合作，利用一些……基本上是利用那些可用于招聘人员的资金。所以我们要做的的事情之一就是招聘对Ruby
gems and that sort of thing. And I think that that effort is starting up. And I guess if someone out there listening is like, you know what, I have this really great proposal to improve this, that, and the other thing. Yeah, I'll figure out a link in the show notes to shoot over to that for that. For HashiCorp specifically, yeah, I mean, we've been all remote since the inception. So almost a decade now. The co-founders were remote from each other or have been remote from each other for eight of those decades, eight of those 10 years or so.
宝石之类东西感兴趣的人。而且我认为这项工作正在开始。我想如果外面的某个听众觉得，你知道吗，我有一个非常棒的提案来改进这个、那个以及其他事情。是的，我会弄一个链接放在节目简介里发过去。具体到HashiCorp，是的，我的意思是，我们自成立以来就一直是全远程的。所以差不多有十年了。联合创始人彼此远程，或者说在过去的十年左右的时间里，有八年的时间彼此都是远程的。
So we have HashiCorp.com slash jobs, I believe, working on all kinds of different things. A number of Ruby jobs as well. Cool. Yeah, I've used, I think Terraform and Vault are both Hashicorp projects. Yeah, I didn't realize there was a big Ruby footprint there. Yeah, Terraform Cloud, which is our Terraform app, The SaaS offering is all written in Rails. Wow. Did not know that. That is what, actually, this is a bit curious. If you are going to a website, is there a telltale sign that this was written in Rails? Is there something that kind of gives it away? Like I'm trying to think like maybe it's a developer tools. Not as much anymore. As everybody has moved to RESTful routes, it's harder to tell.
所以我们有HashiCorp.com slash jobs，我想，上面有各种各样的职位。也有很多Ruby的工作。酷。是的，我用过，我想Terraform和Vault都是Hashicorp的项目。是的，我没意识到那里有那么大的Ruby足迹。是的，Terraform Cloud，也就是我们的Terraform应用，SaaS产品全部是用Rails编写的。哇。不知道呢。这其实是，这有点奇怪。如果你去一个网站，有没有什么明显的迹象表明这是用Rails编写的？有什么东西能泄露出来吗？就像我在想，也许它是一个开发者工具。现在没那么多了。随着大家都转向了RESTful路由，这更难分辨了。
You could probably look at maybe some of the headers to try and figure out like, oh, this looks like the pattern that is injected by this asset management framework that's available in Rails. But that's pretty minor because everybody has sort of copied the same techniques over time so not as much anymore yeah no people stop putting the old powered by php buttons on the bottom of the in the footers you know what do you think i'm all for it yeah yeah i love those i love the powered by uh you know linux powered by php little buttons that people put down there so that was in the days pre like what we're talking about at the top of the show of pre-cookies cookie tracking and
你也许可以查看一些标头，试图弄清楚，哦，这看起来像是Rails中可用的那个资产管理框架注入的模式。但这非常微不足道，因为随着时间的推移，每个人都复制了相同的技术，所以现在没那么多了，是的，人们不再在页脚底部放置旧的powered by php按钮了。你知道吗，你怎么看，我完全赞成。是的，我喜欢那些，我喜欢那些powered by，呃，你知道的，Linux，powered by php的小按钮，人们把它们放在下面。所以那是在互联网早期，就像我们在节目开头谈到的那样，在Cookie追踪之前，还有
all that kind of thing those those images would go into someone's log so they could find out how many people hit this thing so i could figure out how many people are actually on this website so yep yep very cool actually I just kind of a random question. And then we can we can close it out. But you talked about rest API's. Is there a connection between rails and open API or schwagger? Are these other things? Is there a way to generate that? Is that a is that a thing? Or like, I guess maybe the higher level question is, are people using Rails for API servers? Or is it really just mostly for front-end web servers? 100%.
所有那种东西，那些图片会进入某人的日志，这样他们就能查出有多少人访问了这个东西，这样我就可以弄清楚有多少人真的在这个网站上，所以，非常酷。其实我只是有一个随意的问题。然后我们就可以结束了。但你谈到了REST API。Rails和OpenAPI或Swagger之间有什么联系吗？这些是其他东西吗？有没有办法生成那个？这是一种东西吗？或者说，更高层面的问题是，人们是否在将Rails用于API服务器？还是说它真的主要用于前端Web服务器？100%。
People are definitely using Rails as both a full-stack website, but also just an API server, like 100%. In fact, I think there's actually an option you can pass to the Rails new command, which is like a dash dash API. And what it'll do is it'll just optimize that installation for like a headless API only version of Rails. Shopify's big monolith is primarily a GraphQL API server for the most part, right? Because we do a lot of React on the front end. And so the React is just hitting GraphQL APIs or REST APIs on the back end. And you find that that's where all the complicated business logic is. Anyway,
人们绝对是在将Rails既用作全栈网站，也用作API服务器，就像100%那样。事实上，我认为你其实可以给Rails new命令传递一个选项，就像是--api。它会针对无头、仅API版本的Rails优化该安装。Shopify的大单体在很大程度上主要是一个GraphQL API服务器，对吧？因为我们在前端使用大量的React。所以React只是在后端请求GraphQL API或REST APIs。你会发现所有复杂的业务逻辑都在那里。无论如何，
it's not like it's not easier just because you're not having to render views, right? But yeah, absolutely. Rails is fantastic as an API server. Cool. That's awesome. Well, I want to give both of you some time to just kind of close it out. You know, if there's there's tons of folks out there, a lot of students out there who are just getting started. And what kind of advice would you give them? Maybe, Mike, I'll start with you. Hmm. Stay curious. Hmm. I guess that would be my advice is every every every, um, I think looking back on a 25 year career, all the really fun things I did were because I noticed something that was like broken or wasn't quite right. And I was like, why is that doing that? And then like you do the deep dive and you learn a little bit about your tools and you learn how things break, which teaches you how
这并不是说因为你不需要渲染视图就变得更容易了，对吧？但是是的，绝对的。Rails作为API服务器是非常棒的。酷。太棒了。嗯，我想给你们两人一些时间来做个总结。你知道，如果有成千上万的人在听，有很多刚刚入门的学生。你会给他们什么建议呢？也许，Mike，我从你开始。嗯。保持好奇心。嗯。我想这就是我的建议，每一个，每一个，每一个，嗯，回顾25年的职业生涯，所有真正有趣的事情都是因为我注意到有些东西坏了或者不太对劲。然后我就想，为什么会这样？然后你深入研究，对你的工具了解一点，你了解事情是如何崩溃的，这会教你它们
they're supposed to work, which makes you a better engineer. And usually you get like a great cocktail party story out of it at the end of it all too, where you go, you're not going to believe what I found at work today. And just stay curious. And as long as you, as long as you're doing that, I think that's, that's the best advice I can give anyone. Yeah. I'll piggyback on that and push it even more. I've, I've talked about this with, with other people before, but like, I'm not generally a life planner, right? Like I don't plan, I didn't plan out a career. I didn't plan out most of anything. Vacations is basically what I plan out. That's about it. And, but I feel like I've been very lucky and looking back on my luck over time, I feel like it's one of those elements where I mostly just took the thing that
应该如何工作，这会让你成为一个更好的工程师。而且通常在这一切结束时，你还能从中得到一个很棒的鸡尾酒会故事，你会说，你不会相信我今天在工作中所发现的东西。只要保持好奇心。只要你，只要你一直在这样做，我认为这就是我能给任何人的最好建议。是的。我将在那基础上继续推进。我以前跟其他人讨论过这个，但是，我通常不是一个生活规划者，对吧？我不做规划，我没有规划过职业生涯。我大部分事情都没规划过。度假基本上是我规划的唯一事情。差不多就是这样。但是，我觉得我非常幸运，回首我一路走来的运气，我觉得这属于那种我基本上只是挑选了
was most interesting that really, I trusted my gut about the thing that was most interesting to just go and say like, I'm going to do that next. That's the thing I'm going to do next, right? I'm interested in it. So I had to have interest. So again, to Mike's point, like be curious, like, you know, like if you think that this sounds interesting, like, just do a little research, look it up, like, like, be try different things, right? I think that you will be amazed at how those things more than more so than even a cocktail party, you know, you'd be amazed at like, oh, I looked at this thing. And now it's perfectly applicable to what I'm doing every day or or in your interview. And you may say, like, do you have an interesting story?
最有趣的事情，我凭直觉相信最有趣的事情，然后就去说，我接下来要做这个。那是我接下来要做的事情，对吧？我对它感兴趣。所以我必须有兴趣。所以再次回到Mike的观点，要保持好奇心，你知道，如果你觉得这听起来很有趣，就去做点研究，查一查，尝试不同的事情，对吧？你会惊讶于这些事情，甚至比鸡尾酒会的故事更甚，你会惊讶于，哦，我研究了这个东西，现在它完美地适用于我每天所做的事情，或者在你的面试中。你可能会说，你有什么有趣的故事吗？
And you tell them the story and be like, that's amazing. I had the same problem like those. The tech community is amazingly small, but amazingly wide in terms of breadth. Right. So, like, if you had some weird little thing that you did, you might find that somebody else had that same thing. And that might be you're in to have a conversation with them about a job. Or if you are really interested in this thing that maybe you can't figure out how to do right now, you might just continue to cultivate that and find out that later on. Now there's that thing sort of appears.
然后你把故事讲给他们听，他们会说，太神奇了。我有过同样的问题，类似这样的。科技社区小得惊人，但在广度上又大得惊人。对吧。所以，如果你做了一些奇怪的小事情，你可能会发现别人也有同样的经历。这可能就是你与他们开启工作对话的契机。或者，如果你对某件你现在还不知道该怎么做的事情真的很感兴趣，你可能会继续培养这种兴趣，并发现以后，那个东西某种程度上出现了。
It might feel like luck, but really it's you making your own luck. Yeah, really, really well said. You might even get to the point where you've only done machine learning. You could still talk about fork and spawn and how painful they are. Exactly. Someone who's done Ruby. Yeah. It's amazing. A real treasure and a pleasure having you both on the show. I really appreciate it. Absolutely fascinating interview. Thank you again on the show. I really appreciate it.
这可能感觉像是运气，但实际上是你自己创造了运气。是的，说得太好了。你甚至可能会达到这样的地步：你只做过机器学习。你仍然可以谈论fork和spawn以及它们有多痛苦。没错。一个做过Ruby的人。太棒了。非常荣幸能邀请到两位来到节目中。我真的很感激。绝对是一场精彩绝伦的访谈。再次感谢你们来到节目。我真的很感激。
Absolutely fascinating interview. Thank you again for your time. Thank you for having us. Oh, my pleasure. Yeah. Cool. And thank you folks out there for listening, supporting us on Patreon. It's getting close to the holiday episode. By the time this goes out, it'll probably be about two months away, maybe six weeks.
绝对是一场精彩绝伦的访谈。再次感谢你们抽出时间。谢谢你们邀请我们。哦，我的荣幸。是的。酷。也谢谢在外面收听、在Patreon上支持我们的朋友们。快到节日特辑了。当这期节目播出时，可能大概还有两个月，也许六周。
But Patrick and I are already planning a pretty awesome holiday episode at the end of the year to kind of round it out. And yeah, thanks again for supporting us on Audible and sending us emails. We really appreciate all of the feedback that we get. Thanks a lot, guys. See you later. Music by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commonsons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但帕特里克和我已经在规划年底的一个相当棒的节日特辑来为这一年收尾。是的，再次感谢你们在Audible上支持我们并给我们发电子邮件。我们非常感谢收到的所有反馈。非常感谢，伙计们。再见。Eric Barndollar配乐。Programming Throwdown根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议分发，你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，修改、改编作品，但你必须注明署名归帕特里克和我，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可留下评论。